all right
[Music]
foreign
do we have any preliminary matters
before the jury okay sure sure
yes
foreign
foreign
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen all right you have a seat or
your next Witness
your honor we call uh Travis mcgivern by
video link
Mr mcgivern can you hear me
all right
can you do me a favor and just count to
five for me so I get you to pop up on my
big screen here
right now can you turn your camera on
I thought it was on there we go yes sir
now I can see you if you could raise
your right hand sir
do you swear for him to tell the truth
on a penalty of law
yes I do all right thank you thank you
man
good morning Mr mcgivern
good morning could you please State your
full name for the record
Travis Edward mcgivern
and where do you currently live
Los Angeles California
where are you testifying from today
Los Angeles California
what is your current occupation
I am a security professional
and how long have you been a security
professional
roughly 16 years a little over 16 years
do you know the plaintiff in this case
Johnny Depp
yes I do
how do you know Mr Depp
I've worked for Mr Depp for
a little over nine years
and what's your position for Mr Depp
security professional
um
personal protection
when did you first start working for Mr
Depp
March
of
2013.
and when did you first meet Mr Depp
couldn't say for sure
um probably sometime
around then March or April 2013.
what do you do as a member of Mr Depp's
security team
um
residential security Estate Security if
he's in LA
when he's in La if he
I'll take him wherever he wants to go I
have
um
protected his children before
um
yeah just basically ensure the
safety and well-being of Mr Depp and his
family
and are you currently employed for Mr
Deb
what other means of employment do you
have
um so
Mr Depp's travel schedule is
pretty regular so when he's not in town
um work slows down a little bit so I
have
actually in the last six months
just under six months picked up a
full-time job working for another client
when you first started working for Mr
Depp how often would you see him in
person
hard to say when he's in town I saw him
on a daily and or nightly basis I work
nights mostly
um
obviously when he's out of town that
that changes but
um yeah when he's in town pretty much
daily
when did you first meet Miss heard
I couldn't give you an exact date but I
would say sometime in 2013 maybe summer
2013.
and when you were working for Mr Depp
how often would you see misheard when
they were in a relationship
in the beginning not very often
at one point they moved to downtown L.A
to the Eastern Columbia building and
became a little more frequent
uh when Mr Deb and Miss heard were
staying at the Eastern Columbia building
together how often would you actually be
in their apartment with them
that would vary uh depending on
the situation but
a few times a week would be my my best
estimate it again it depended on what
was going on and there'd be nights where
I wouldn't see them at all there'd be
nights
where where I would
um best best estimate would be a few
times a week
during that time did you have occasion
to see Mr Depp and misheard interacting
with each other
I did yeah
and how often would you estimate
the time I was in there they were
typically interacting so I'd say a few a
few times a week
several times a week
how would you describe the interactions
between Mr death and misheard
it would I mean they were it would
depend sometimes they were
super loving super
um
and then the next night they could be
arguing and
initially when we first
when I first started working down at the
Lofts that things were cool
um
more than
more than moving forward things got a
little more volatile
moving in the longer they were there
when did you start noticing more
arguments between Mr Depp and misheard
so
I want to say like the end of 2014 they
started staying down there pretty
regularly there were a few incidents
where
there were fights
um
but March 2015 when when they came back
from Australia was when
I really started to notice notice a
change
and how often would you witness
arguments or fights during that time
from in in March
from March and thereafter
so when I came back from Australia that
the arguments were pretty regular
um
wouldn't say nightly but
every other night uh
several times a week there there would
be
arguments
and what did you observe in the
arguments that you personally witnessed
so it was typically I would come in
I'd get a text from Mr Depp
I would go to Penthouse three which is
where they stayed
um
either stay by the door
as requested or
in the kitchen
um
and then I mean it was just verbal
verbal arguments
um
yelling uh
it was typically Mr Depp wanting to get
out of there and
so there was the try
trying to convince Miss heard that to
let us leave and yeah I mean lots of
name-calling lots of
f-bombs you know
and who was the name calling directed at
so that was typically misheard directing
her
feelings toward Mr death and what do you
recall Miss heard saying in those
instances
oh dear
um
it would vary and to be honest I I tried
to not pay attention I was just there to
get Mr Depp out of there but
um
you know there were times I've heard
misheard call him uh
[ __ ] deadbeat dad
if I can say that I apologize to the
court if
um a
[ __ ] washed up
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
um
you name it I she she's spewed it
how would you describe your own
interactions with Miss heard in the time
that you worked for Mr dub
it's the relevance of his interactions
uh his interaction start when he was
involved in the when he was witnessing
these altercations my wife won't ask
that question okay how would you
describe your interactions with Miss
heard when you were present during an
altercation between her and Mr Depp
for the most part
there wasn't really interaction
um
there was there were a few times where
um I was trying to get Mr Depp away from
the situation and misheard
didn't like my involvement in the
situation
um and she
on one occasion let me know how she felt
about about that and what did she say to
you in that instance
hmm
a lot it was a a lengthy
um
one-sided conversation
um but she basically demeaned
my career choice
called me a [ __ ] yes man
um
and honestly there were parts of that
where she
you know she was like how would how
would you feel if someone was involved
in your relationship
which I sympathize with
um
but
yeah she she definitely threw some
shade on me and and my
chosen career
now you mentioned that
um the arguments between Mr Depp and
misheard increased when they returned
from Australia in March 2015.
um when did you first see Miss heard
when she returned from Australia
so I picked Miss heard up from the
airport
on March 9th
yeah that was that was the first time I
saw her when she got back and who else
was with her
a gentleman named Ben King
who I later found out I didn't know who
he was initially but uh later found out
he was the
house manager or property estate manager
of the the place they were staying at in
Australia
how would you describe Ms heard's
demeanor when you picked her up at the
airport
she seemed normal nothing nothing out of
the ordinary
um
she was pleasant she was polite
like like she usually was
how much time did you spend with Miss
heard that day
not a lot but at least the car ride from
LAX
to downtown L.A to The Lofts
um
couldn't tell you how long that took but
probably
45 minutes to an hour
um
I believe I escorted them or helped them
up to Penthouse three and was maybe in
there for
very very briefly a minute or two and
then
um
and then I left so overall let's let's
estimate an hour
and how close to you how close to
misheard were you that day
I mean in the car where I'm driving
she's in the the seat right behind me to
my right so there's a few feet there
I think when I picked them up
I don't remember if I hugged her or not
but I know I'd probably grab some
luggage so I was I was within a few feet
and what time of day was it when Miss
heard arrived at the airport
early afternoon
um I want to say they landed at around 1
00
pm
what if any injuries Did You observe on
misheard that day
notice any injury
when did you first see Mr Depp when he
returned from Australia in March 2015.
I don't know to be honest
um
I know it was after Miss hurricane
but I couldn't give you an exact date
and what if any injuries Did You observe
on Mr Depp when he returned from
Australia
Mr dab had his hand his right hand
um
heavily wrapped
I didn't actually see an injury but his
hand was
um
was wrapped
now you mentioned that the arguments
between Mr Depp and misheard increased
after they returned from Australia what
arguments do you recall specifically
one in particular stands out
March 23rd
a couple weeks after they got back there
was a
an incident in Penthouse 5 that
I recall
and when did you start your shift that
day
11 p.m was typically my start time
and where were you on your shift
so we at The Lofts there was um
kind of a makeshift command post CP or
uh guard shack or whatever it's called
um
that was in a storage room connected to
Penthouse five
via a patio so you leave Penthouse five
go to a patio and then
our
CP was connected to that patio
that's typically where we hang out
during during our shifts
and what time were you first contacted
by Mr Duff that evening
hmm
again I can't say precisely but
between four and
probably around 4 a.m 4 30 Maybe
and what did you do after Mr Depp
contacted you
so when he he texted me and um
I was downstairs
I don't remember exactly what I was
doing either getting some air stretching
my legs
or grabbing some food
um
but I remember getting the text I wasn't
in the CP when I got the text
um
he requested I meet him at Penthouse
five
and requested that I bring the nurse his
nurse that was working at that time with
him
what was her name
Debbie Lloyd
and so what did you did you um go get
Miss Lloyd
I did so
Miss Miss Lloyd was staying at a hotel
um close by probably about a half block
away
and being that I was already down there
I felt
uh four in the morning I wasn't gonna
and Mr Depp wouldn't have wanted me to
have her walk by herself
um
but I wasn't gonna go get the truck
either since I was down there already so
I walked over the hotel I I believe I
called the nurse just to make sure she
woke up
um and then I walked to the hotel and I
met her there
we walked over together to the Eastern
Columbia building
um
in the lobby we ran into Miss heard she
was at the front desk talking to
security or concierge I'm not sure who
[Music]
um
Miss Lloyd stayed downstairs with Miss
heard I proceeded upstairs to meet Mr
Depp at Penthouse five as requested
um
was hoping to get him out of there
before misheard
came back up
um just because of plastic
sorry why was that
just because past experiences when they
would argue she would
try to prevent us from leaving
um
to the point I mean she's held the
elevator before she's physically tried
to keep Mr Depp from leaving by grabbing
his arm or stand in front of them
I just wanted to get out of there to
avoid that
and what happened when you got upstairs
to the penthouse
so Mr Depp was sitting
in front of the the front door of
Penthouse five
um
I agree he had some bags I believe like
he was ready to go
um I greeted him
kind of got a feel for what was going on
tried to get him out of there
um
as we were getting ready to leave Miss
heard and Miss Lloyd
exited the elevator on the penthouse
level so they came back up
and um
Mr Depp and misheard
decided they wanted to continue
whatever conversation they were having
so
I let them into Penthouse five
um
myself Miss Lloyd Mr Gap and Miss heard
entered Penthouse five
I tried to stay out of their
conversations as long as they were
peaceful so
they were having a
relatively peaceful conversation so miss
Lloyd and I stood outside the door
of Penthouse five had the door propped
open
um to make sure we could hear what was
going on but kind of giving them their
space
uh initially
and you said initially what happened
after that
so the conversation
um got a little louder got a little more
volatile so
Miss Lloyd and myself entered Penthouse
five
um
just to be around
um to
hopefully be able to
not necessarily mediate but just to be
there
um
so yeah enter stood a little closer to
Mr Depp
and what did you observe when you went
back into the penthouse
so the argument continued
um there were moments of kind of normal
conversation uh peaceful conversation
but then there were also moments of
yelling and anger from from both of them
um
and at some point I witnessed Miss heard
throw a Red Bull can so
The Loft is three levels
um Mr Depp was down at the lower level
which is the kitchen area there's a
middle level which is was turned into an
office for misheard and then the upper
level was where the bedrooms were but
they were turned into
that's closets basically for misheard at
that time
um Miss heard and her sister at that
time
um
Whitney had had come in they were both
on the the middle level the office level
um
and I I saw Miss heard throw a Red Bull
can
from her position
um that struck Mr Depp in the back
anything else that you recall
at that point I moved closer to Mr death
I didn't care
um that I was
in the middle of their conversation at
that point I didn't want my client
getting hit with anything else so
I stood right by Mr debb
um
the verbal
uh
Onslaught continued from from both of
them
um
Mr Depp was giving as good as he got at
that point he was he was angry and
agitated
um
at one point misheard through something
else uh either a purse or some sort of
bag or something that she had up there
um
I was able to knock it away so it didn't
hit him
at one point she spit at him
um
yeah and then just just a lot of
a lot of verbal
vitriol from both of them
what do you remember Miss heard saying
to Mr Depp on this occasion
cheese
anything and everything specifically
there was the you're [ __ ] washed up
um
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh which which he called her as well
um
you're
again the deadbeat dad [ __ ]
um
yeah I don't even remember what the
fight was about but it was um
it was pretty
the f word is my favorite word and it
was being thrown around
to the point where I was uncomfortable
so
and how did Mr Depp respond to
misheard's behavior
oh he was mad he was upset
um
especially after
she tried to spit on him
at one point
Miss heard and her sister
laughed
um Penthouse five
I imagine they went into Penthouse four
or possibly over to Penthouse three I
don't know if they were all adjoining
Mr death went upstairs and
rearranged her closet for her
um
threw down
probably every rack of clothing and
shoes
through one at least one down the stairs
um
yeah he he was upset
where was Miss heard when Mr Depp
rearranged her closet as you said
yeah say for sure but she was not in
Penthouse five she was either in four or
three
and you mentioned misheard's sister
Whitney do you recall when she arrived
in the evening
so Whitney wasn't there when we first
all walked into penthouse
um
When Miss Lloyd and I stepped out to
give them some space she must have
she must have come in at some point
because she was in there when we got
when we walked back
did you see Miss heard again that
evening after Mr Depp was in her closet
I did yeah she must have heard what was
going on and not been too pleased so she
shortly after re-entered um Penthouse
ride
as I was trying to get Mr Depp
out of there
and what happened at that point
so her and her sister both came back in
um we were on the
middle level so her office level of of
Penthouse five at that point
um she was agitated
Mr Depp was agitated
uh
I felt it was time to get Mr Depp out of
the situation so I stepped
in between Miss heard and Mr Depp
um
telling Mr Depp that we were that we
were leaving and that it wasn't up to
him anymore
um
at that point
out of the corner of my eye I saw a fist
and an arm come
across my right shoulder and uh
I heard and saw a
closed fist contact Mr depth and the
left side of his face
and whose fist was that
that was Miss herds fifth Amber heard's
Fist and where was where was Whitney
when this occurred
can't say for sure but I'm guessing or
my best guess is behind
um Amber
how did Mr Depp respond when he was
punched
the initial look on his face
kind of mirrored mine uh kind of a look
of shock like what just happened where'd
that come from
um
at that point
uh I wasn't gonna let Mr Depp get hit
anymore so I
moved him down the last flight of stairs
to the lower level
um
and told him we're leaving like it
wasn't it wasn't up to him anymore
um just for his safety I didn't again I
had let him get hit by a Red Bull can I
let him get punched
my job is to ensure the safety and
well-being of my clients and
I felt like I hadn't done that so
um
it was my time to do my job and get him
out of there
and so uh where did you go
so miss herden her sister
um
left Penthouse five
again I don't know where they went I'm
assuming they went through Penthouse
four
we're either in four or three
Mr Depp
um was not pleased with me
naturally
um he went into the bathroom for a
couple minutes Miss Lloyd talked to him
um
and they came out and agreed that it was
time to leave
so as as we were leaving the front door
uh
Mr Depp
got right in my face he was wearing
sunglasses
and uh maybe not sunglasses he was
wearing glasses
um pulled him down pointed to the left
side of his face and told me that's your
fault
and I agreed
um and then we proceeded to the vehicle
and and we left the laws what did you
see on the left side of Mr Depp's face
uh it was it was already a nice little
nice little Shiner
um
definitely swollen and red uh
it wasn't black and blue yet but it was
definitely swollen and red
at any point during this incident did Mr
Depp throw anything at misheard
no
at any point did Mr Depp throw anything
at anyone
no
at any time during this incident did Mr
Depp physically respond to miss heard
no
do you recall Miss heard's birthday
party in April of 2016.
I do
uh Mr mcgivern during the incident we
just discussed on March 23rd um
what did Mr Depp have on his right hand
so he had the same band
and he arrived from Australia so it was
heavily wrapped
um
yeah a heavily wrapped bandage I don't
know what was underneath but it was it
was definitely wrapped
do you recall whether it was a hard or a
soft cast
I do not
okay now moving forward to miss heard's
birthday party in April 2016.
um
were you present at that dinner party
I was not
um
I started my shift
again around 11 P.M
the party was going on in Penthouse five
um
I don't
typically take part in get togethers so
I think I would probably hung out in the
CP
um shortly after I got there the party
kind of winded down
um
I believe Mr Depp got there
he was late
um so I think he got there shortly after
I started my shift
um he went into Penthouse five again the
party wound down shortly thereafter and
then as far as I know Mr Depp and
misheard went back to Penthouse three
um shortly thereafter
did you see Mr Depp again that evening
that morning I did early that morning
yeah uh or the following morning
um
again I got a text
my best guess is around the same time
four there were so many
so many incidences
um I they're hard to keep straight but
um probably around four or five that
morning
requesting my presence in penthouse 3.
and how did what did you do after you
received that text message
entered went to Penthouse three
and what did you observe when you went
to Penthouse three
again a verbal argument
um
I think it was made clear that some
phones had been thrown off
thrown out the window or something
um
down to
Broadway
uh
Mr Depp was again ready to leave to get
out of the situation he had his couple
bags over his shoulders
um
wanted to grab a few valuables that we
always used to grab when this happened
um
some framed letters from
either Hunter S Thompson or Marlon
Brando
um
yeah and then I I believe that we left
uh I think I got him out of the
situation again
we did look for the phone briefly I
think on our way on our way back to West
Hollywood
but my main concern was getting him away
from the situation so I didn't find the
phone
um and then we we proceeded back to
back to his future properties
what do you recall about Miss heard's
demeanor that evening when you saw her
nothing out of the ordinary nothing that
I mean they were they were arguing like
usual in those circumstances but nothing
nothing pops out
what if any injuries Did You observe on
misheard that evening
I didn't notice any injuries
in your time working for Mr Duff have
you ever seen Mr Depp physically abuse
misheard
I have not
now you mentioned a couple occasions how
many times have you witnessed Miss heard
be physically abusive towards Mr Depp
uh obviously the March 23rd thing in
Penthouse five
um
a physically abusive I don't know how to
define that but I have seen her
physically try to prevent him from
leaving before so
grabbing grabbing his arms standing in
front of him pushing him
um
yeah again I don't know if that's
physically abusive but that I've
definitely seen her touch him on
multiple occasions
have you ever observed Mr deputies any
drugs
and what drugs have you seen Mr W's
uh are you talking non-prescription
drugs yes
marijuana
and uh cocaine
how many times have you seen Mr deputy's
marijuana
too many to count I mean daily
and how many times have you seen Mr
deput use cocaine
a couple two
how would you describe Mr Duff's
demeanor when he's using marijuana
chill for lack of a better word
um mellow
uh
yeah I don't know how to better describe
it just super mellow
and how would you describe Mr Depp's
demeanor when you've seen him use
cocaine
the same
um
so I've seen him use it like actual seen
him use it a few times I've
I've known of him using it other times
and
I feel like it it levels him out
um
yeah I haven't noticed any difference
when he when he's used it
have you observed Mr Depp consume
alcohol
absolutely and how many times
like marijuana too many to count pretty
regularly
and on how many of those occasions did
Mr Depp appear to be drunk
it would depend on what you mean by
drunk but not not many
um the only time I would say I've seen
Mr Deb drunk was
uh when he would fall asleep on the
couch sitting up with his boots on
um
other than that Mr Depp
handles his liquor very well
how would you describe Mr Depp's
demeanor when you've seen him consume
alcohol
no no different than
any other time again super super chill
super mellow
yeah
have you ever witnessed misheard consume
alcohol
I have
how many times would you estimate
again two minutes account
um she drank
fairly regularly
um
so I couldn't even give you a
guesstimate
on how many of those occasions Did You
observe misheard behaving drunk
can't say I've other than the the
incident on March 23rd where
I didn't see her drinking but I assumed
based on her behavior
um she was drunk other than that
I can't say I've ever seen her
uh obviously drunk in my eyes
I have no further questions
cross-examination Mr rottenborn
sir
good morning Mr mcgivern
good morning sir so you've you said
you've worked for Mr Depp for about nine
years right
correct and he's he hasn't been in town
recently so you have another job is that
what you said
yes but you still consider yourself an
employee of his even today correct
I do and when you do work for Mr Depp he
pays your salary right
not on salary he pays my my wage yes
okay
he pays the money that you make for
working for him
correct and you've referred to him a few
times during your testimony this morning
as your client is that right
yes so when you're working security for
Mr Depp it's Mr Depp and Mr Depp alone
that is your client correct
that is not correct
well in the the altercation that you
testified about with misheard and Mr
Depp you referred to to only Mr Depp as
your client and it was your job to keep
your clients safe do you remember that
objection compound
I love that good
I do okay
so at least in that instance he was your
client not misheard correct
correct
now
the evening of March 23rd 2015.
you actually walked into the middle of
the argument with Debbie Lloyd correct
yes so
you testified earlier that you were
downstairs and misheard was downstairs
in the lobby and you'd gotten Miss Lloyd
but that's actually not accurate is it
to the best of my recollection that is
accurate in fact when you and Miss Lloyd
entered Penthouse five
Amber and Mr def were already in there
having a verbal argument correct
that is not correct
yeah approach run all right yes sir
thank you
Mr mcgivern do you see
um a document on the screen in front of
you entitled witness statement of Travis
mcgivern
uh
I do
and you
well let me ask you this is that your is
that your address below
the document's pretty small is there any
way for me to oh there we go
yes it is and that's that's where you
currently live
hang on one sec I'm sorry
that is a P.O box okay is that yours
it is okay
um
now this is a witness statement that you
prepared on behalf of Mr Depp uh in the
UK trial correct
yeah the the statement went away oh
there it is you see it yes it is
and
who drafted this statement
myself along with
an attorney I don't remember exactly who
was it Adam Waldman
at that point I don't believe it was no
if you go to paragraph five please
on the second page
and you understood when you wrote this
statement that this was going to be
submitted to the court in the UK trial
that Mr Depp brought
and that this was your testimony on
behalf of Mr Depp correct
yes
and about two-thirds of the way through
paragraph five
there's a sentence that says when Ms
Lloyd and I entered his residence
misheard and Mr Depp were having a
verbal argument
is that correct
that I read that right
that is
yes so that doesn't say anything about
you meeting misheard in the lobby of the
Eastern Columbia building does it
no it does not
and when you entered the penthouse you
can't recall the specifics of what the
argument was about correct
no like what they were fighting about
absolutely no I don't and you don't know
anything about what caused the argument
in the first place correct
I do not but you do remember Mr Depp
being very angry
right
I remember both of them being very angry
yes and you say that he gave as good as
he got
when it came to what they were saying to
each other right
yes
you say they were both being verbally
abusive to one another
yes
and you testified that
at some point misheard misheard was on
the the mezzanine level right the the
level of her office or kind of the
middle level of the penthouse
that's correct and Mr Depp was on the
lower level correct When you entered the
penthouse
so when Miss Lloyd and I re-entered the
penthouse yes that's where they were
and you weren't preventing Mr Depp from
leaving at any time correct
preventing him from leaving I was
encouraging him to leave right and he
could have when he was on that lower
level of the penthouse he could have
left at that point correct you wouldn't
have prevented that
no I would not have
um but instead at some point he walked
up to the mezzanine and as you say he
rearranged Miss hurt's closet
right
well that wasn't on the mezzanine level
that was on the top level
um but yeah he rearranged the closet so
he traveled up two levels in the
penthouse to throw down every rack of
clothing that she had right
I don't know about every rack but he he
definitely threw
food okay I believe you said every rack
so that's just why I was asking you to
confirm that you said he threw a rack
down the stairs correct
yes okay and then at that point he went
back downstairs
to the mezzanine level yes now that
wasn't the only time you learned of Mr
Depp
um
causing damage in Penthouse 5 correct
couldn't say for sure nothing nothing's
coming to mind
he had uh you said he had something on
his hand from his injury that he
sustained in Australia right
yes his hand was wrapped now you weren't
in Australia uh with Mr Depp and
misheard correct
I was not okay
and
what he had on his hand could have been
a hard cast correct
sure
I have I have no idea what was under the
wrap
and isn't it true that while he was on
the mezzanine level and misheard uh and
and her sister were there that he was
reaching for Amber's hair while he was
trying to hit her with that cast correct
foreign
that is not correct and you say that you
can't say for sure where Whitney was
standing on the mezzanine level during
this altercation correct
that is correct and it's it's possible
that she was standing in between Mr Depp
and misheard then correct
no well you say you can't say for sure
where she was standing so she could have
been standing in between Mr Def and
misheard right
no because I stepped in between Miss
heard and Mr Depp
um so she definitely wasn't standing in
between them well in fact you saw Mr
Depp uh push or shove Whitney heard
correct
absolutely not and it was only after Mr
Depp pushed Whitney that Amber stepped
forward and punched him in the face
isn't that right
that is not correct
now moving on to April 2016 you weren't
there for the party you said correct
I arrh I started my shift while the
party was going on but you weren't in
with the party goers you said right
that's correct and you said at some
point Mr Depp and Miss heard went back
to Penthouse three
um but you have no idea what went on
between them and Penthouse three while
you weren't there correct
I do not
and
you said that you
gave Security Services to Mr Depp
primarily in Los Angeles is that right
yes a little bit of travel but mostly in
in L.A okay where'd you travel to
um
Vegas
uh
up north we did a road trip kind of
they called it their honeymoon
um so Napa San Francisco
Big Sur
um
San Jose
uh I've those are all with misheard I've
taken
Mr Depp to China before
um
okay yeah and then a bunch of bunch of
local stuff Palm Springs Santa Barbara
um stuff like that okay you weren't on a
plane flight from Boston to Los Angeles
with Mr Depp and Amber in May 2014
correct
I was not and you weren't at the
Hicksville trailer Palace in May or June
of 2013 correct with them I was not you
uh you were never in the Bahamas with
them including in August 2014 correct
I was not you were not in the Bahamas
with them in December of 2015 correct
I was not you were not in Tokyo with
them in January of 2015 correct
I was not you were not in the Eastern
Columbia building with them on the
evening of December 15 2015 correct
I don't know
um to the best of your recollection
yeah if they were at The Lofts I
typically worked
every night but nothing
about December 15th is popping into my
head okay and you definitely were not in
the Eastern Columbia building with them
on the night of May 21st 2016 were you
I was not okay
um nothing further thank you Mr Morgan
all right no your honor all right is
this witness all right is this witness
subject to recall
uh yes your honored all right Mr
mcgibbon you're subject to recall so uh
just let you know uh you're still
subject to the rule on Witnesses so you
cannot talk to anybody about your
testimony or uh watch any of the
proceedings of this case okay sir
I understood man all right thank you
have a good day
your next witness
um Mr Depp calls Jack Wiggum who should
be waiting in the electronic Lobby okay
all right Mr Wickham can you hear me sir
could you do me a favor and just count
to one to five for me
sure one two three four five all right
thank you sir can you raise your right
hand
okay do you swear from tell the truth on
a penalty of law
okay thank you sir
good morning Mr Wiggum would you please
State your full name for the record
sure it's uh Jack Wiggum
where do you live Mr Wiggum
I live in Los Angeles
where if at all did you earn your
undergraduate degree
I earned a degree in finance from the
University of Florida
in what year of femi did you graduate
from the University of Florida
1998
do you have any graduate degrees Mr
Wiggum
I do I have a degree also
2002.
Mr Wiggum what do you currently do for a
living
I'm currently a manager representative
for artists
would you please describe Mr Wiggum for
the jury what a manager representative
does
so we you know represent writers
directors actors actresses uh mostly in
their pursuit of Artistic Endeavors so I
primarily focus on on film and
television but you know all Artistic
Endeavors
how does a manager representative get
paid
typically via
what
what industry theater is kind of 10 of
whatever the deal is and Mr Wiggum what
did you do professionally after you
earned your JD at the University of
Florida
I was an attorney at
Garfield and manges for approximately
three years
and then I segued from there to a talent
agency called CAA creative artist agency
in what year did you start work at CAA
I started there in April of 2004.
and Mr wiggeman what capacity did you
start working at CIA
I started at the bottom uh in the mail
room uh shut the mail and then uh
became an assistant for one of the one
of your partners and then in 2007 I
believe I was from I became an agent and
then right around
2014 I think I began co-running the film
and talent Department there and when
your job responsibility shifted to
becoming an agent at CAA would you
please describe briefly for the jury
what that entailed
sure we were you know also looking out
for Artistic Endeavors on behalf of the
clients so writers directors actors
actresses but we were also negotiating
deals uh and you know really pursuing
film television producing deals on
behalf of the clients Mr Wiggum did
there come a time when you left CAA
I did I I left in in August of 2020.
what if anything did you do
professionally after you left CAA in
August of 2020.
so I co-founded a management production
company called range Media Partners in
in August of 2020 and have been working
there ever since what type of company is
range Media Partners
it's a management representation
production company
do you know Johnny Depp
I do
Mr Wiggum when did you first meet Mr
Tapp
I I actually met him very
in on the set of black bass which was
probably I don't know 2014 or 15 and
then I met him very briefly out of one
of his music shows uh but more
substantively I sat with him uh I
believe it in the uh the fall of 2016.
did there come a time Mr Wiggum when you
became Mr Depp's agent
yes when was that
right right around October I believe
fall of 2016. was that when you were
still with CAA
yes
when you first started with Mr dappas's
agent who if anyone assisted assisted
you
I had two partners that I worked with
Johnny uh one was Brian Lord and the
other was Christian Carino
since starting to work with Mr depas's
agent in October 2016. have you had
opportunities to observe him interacting
with yourself and others
yes how would you describe for the jury
Mr Depp's demeanor on those occasions
objection relevant
the relevance is how he how he conducts
himself professionally which relates to
his reputation which is at issue all
right I'll overrule the objection go
ahead
you may answer the question
sure uh I Johnny was always very nice
sweet in fact
um
you know artistic uh polite and you know
very thoughtful you know kind of
uniquely thoughtful about
how are you doing how's your family you
know he was he was just a thoughtful
person he always has it that he seem gen
did he seem genuine Jackson leading
oh sustain the objection
to what extent if any did he seem
genuine
I'm going to object how how would he
know
not sure what objection that is or
speculation speculation Foundation I
believe he can he can testify as to that
out loud go ahead
his her honor says her honor says you
may answer that question
uh I found Johnny to be authentic you
know it was
a genuine uh kindness
and Mr wiggin prior to your first
becoming Mr Depp's agent in 2016 October
of 2016. who was his agent prior to that
I believe it was
um Tracy Jacobs at a company called UTA
and before you took over from Tracy
Jacobs as Mr Depp's agent what if any
research or due diligence did you do
with respect to him
again your honor it goes to reputation
which is this the core of the issue I'll
sustain the I'll sustain the objection
next question thank you
were you aware of Mr Depp's professional
reputation at the time you became his
agent in October of 2016.
I would say
dead call for here
I'll overrule at this point okay
I believe I was
what was your understanding if any of Mr
Depp's professional reputation at the
time you began representing him as his
agent in the fall of 2016.
uh
Johnny's reputation in my opinion was
very he was very well regarded and
respected by peers in the artistic
Community
um
I'm going to object he first of all he
says in his opinion which he's not an
expert witness and second he's now going
into hearsay I'll rule the objection go
ahead
you may continue
uh
uh well-regarded respected extremely
talented artistic
are you familiar Mr Wiggum with the
distinction between an independent film
and a studio film
what if any difference is there between
an independent film on one hand and a
studio film on the other
so in in layman's terms I'd say that you
know a studio film is a bigger budgeted
film it's it has a distributor a studio
in place so when you think of Disney
Marvel universal these kind of these are
big companies uh their their bigger
budgeted and bigger fees and then
Independence like we call them Indies
typically are smaller budgeted more
artistically minded smaller fees and
often don't have distribution when
they're made
starting in October 2016 what types of
opportunities have you pursued on Mr
Depp's behalf
a wide variety you know
primarily I would say focused on on film
television and producing
what if any roles did Mr Depp have in
progress as of that time fall of 2016
going into calendar year 2017.
all right so
we we inherited
some deals it was uh there was two films
as I remember that we're going to go
back to back one
was city of Lies the Notorious B.I.G
film and the other was murder on the
Orient Express so those those were
filmed almost at the same time
uh and then and they had pre-existing
deals uh that we serviced
and then he had Fantastic Beasts crimes
of Grindelwald
uh as well and then
we were we were in the process we ended
up finishing the sixth
film negotiation on Pirates the
Caribbean
Mr Wiggum you mentioned city of lives
when was that film actually shot
to the best of my memory it was shot
right you know at the very end mostly
the beginning of 2017.
what was Mr Depp's compensation for city
of Lies
and you mentioned murder on the Orient
Express when was that shot
so
which one went first they were both shot
predominantly call it January to April
of
2017. I remember us having to work out
dates uh but they were it was the
beginning of 2017.
what was Mr Depp's compensation for
murder on the Orient Express
a memory serves me I think it was 10
million dollars
was murder a studio film or an
independent or what you call an indie
film
Mr Wiggum you also mentioned Fantastic
Beasts to crimes of Grindelwald when was
that film shot
I I believe that film was shot in the
fall of 2017.
what was Mr Depp's compensation for
crimes of Grindelwald
again that deal predated us I think it
was 13.5 million if I remember correctly
was crimes of Grindelwald a studio film
or an indie film
it was Studio it was uh Warner Brothers
and backing up a bit Mr Wiggum uh what
was the first business opportunity you
were able to secure for Mr Depp after he
came to you and CAA in the fall of 2016.
so I believe it was we
2017 was really it was busy he we had a
slot that summer and he wanted to do a
smaller film and it was uh the professor
I believe
how much compensation if any did he
receive for performing in that smaller
film The Professor
that deal was uh three and a half
million
was the professor an independent film or
was it a studio film
it was independent
and Mr Wiggum how if it all was CAA
compensated for closing the deal on the
professor
so it would have been the normal uh 10
of the deal so
the deal was three three and a half
million the commission would be 350 000
to the agency
Mr Wiggum was 2017 a typical year for Mr
Depp in terms of the workload for an
actor of his caliber and track record
objection leading
yes
what other roles if any were you able to
secure for Mr Depp during your tenure at
CAA before you went to the new company
uh
a film called waiting for the barbarians
and a film called minamata
when was waiting for the Barbarian shot
it's waiting for the barbarians was
uh
fall of 2018.
what if any plans did you and Mr Depp
have for 2018 calendar year 2018.
we had a very specific plan for that
year because 2017 was busy and he had he
had done Three Studio films
and I remember him wanting to take time
off to rest and be with his kids for
first half the year and then
he wanted to go on a Music Tour which is
always
just made him really happy and so that
was the summer
of 2018 and then
and then we had the slot for two for the
fall of 2018 and uh that's where we
spent a lot of time thinking about what
that movie was going to be and waiting
for the barbarians
it's kind of a little gift because it
was based on a JM cutie novel and
Johnny's you know very well read and
knew the literature the underlying book
and Mark rylance was in the film and it
was just like a dream actor that he
always wanted to work with
what was Mr Depp paid for waiting for
the barbarians
one million dollars and I apologize if
you've already said this was waiting for
the Barbarians in an independent film or
a studio film
Mr Wiggum you also mentioned the film
minamata when was that film shot
that that was the very beginning of
2019. so I think January start was
minimata an indie film or a studio film
it was uh independent
how much was Mr Depp ultimately paid for
minamata
three million dollars
what if any role did Mr Depp play in
Pirates of the Caribbean five
he played uh Captain Jack Sparrow was he
paid an actor's fee for that film
technically it was before my tenure uh
so uh but yes I would assume he was
Mr Wiggum would you please explain for
the jury what are residual or back end
right
I think the easiest way to explain a
back end is is it's an ownership stake
on behalf of the artist uh in the
success of the movie and typically is
only granted to stars of a certain
stature and in addition to the fee Mr
Depp the upfront fee that Mr Depp was
paid for a fantastic Beast five which I
know preceded you uh what if any did
understand what if any understanding do
you have of whether Mr Depp had any back
end rights for pirates five
Jackson your honor Foundation Foundation
he said that deal was at the other
agency and he does he wasn't a lot of he
knows it that's fine go ahead
her honor says she may answer the
question
so you initially said Fantastic Beasts I
think you meant pirate five uh oh I I
apologize I I did mean for pyrex5 uh
what if any back end did Mr Depp have
for pirates five
uh I don't know what it was I know that
he had one
two it to what extent if any did Mr Depp
ever have a deal to perform in Pirate
six
so when we started representing him I
remember Brian Lord and myself finishing
a deal that had started at the previous
agency objection your honor may we
approach okay
hold on a minute
for the interruption Mr Wiggum uh her
honor says you may answer the question
which I believe is to what extent if any
did Mr Depp have ever have a deal to
perform in Pirates six
so we we finished the deal and then we
closed the vehicle in 22 and a half
million for that film is my memory
which studio which studio was involved
in the pirate series including pirate
six
so that was uh Disney
was Disney the studio involved in all of
the Pirates movies
yes
what role was Mr Depp to play in Pirate
six
I love it
I love it
Captain Jack Sparrow
was the 22.5 million to be paid to Mr
Depp by Disney or by some other entity
Disney
and when was that 22.5 million to be
paid to Mr Depp
it would be paid when you shoot to
become like principal photography so
when the film shoots
who was the producer of the Pirates
franchise
Jerry Bruckheimer does Mr Bruckheimer
work for Disney
in 2017 to what extent if any was Mr
Bruckheimer supportive of Mr Depp
remaining in the Pirates franchise
objections I'll sustained injection
thank you Ronnie
putting aside his role in the Pirates
films did Mr dapp have any other
affiliations with Disney in 2017
yes
what were those affiliations
he
if I remember in the spring he
went down to Disney 's end and
Captain Jack Sparrow outfit and uh
wardrobe and went into the ride Disney
and Disney had worked out a fun little
thing where he was going to take the
place of the automated you know Captain
Jack Sparrow on the on the Pirates ride
and so he would kind of surprise people
as they were going along there and so I
remember he did that and then
in 2000 in May of 2017 we
uh he went to Disney Shanghai to help
open the Pirates of the Caribbean ride
there uh
what if anything did those affiliations
signify about the status of Mr Depp's
relationship with Disney as of that time
Jack
stating the objection next question
thank your honor uh to what extent of
any did Mr Depp socialize with anyone at
Disney in 2017 to the extent you know
do you know whether Mr Depp socialized
with Disney during 2017 yes or no
Foundation
how do you know that Mr Depp socialized
with Disney and calendar year 2017.
because I was there
who
um would you please describe for the
jury what you mean when you said you
were there when Mr Depp socialized with
Disney
we had a dinner and
spring of 2017 with myself uh Jerry
Bruckheimer Johnny and Sean Bailey who
was running
the film you know was running was
president of Disney
how did the dinner conclude
great I mean very very nice it was it
was a great dinner
as of early December 2018 so we're now
in December of 2018.
uh what if anything was your
understanding of the status of whether
Mr Depp would actually appear in Pirate
six objection
objection next question
Mr Wiggum did there come a time when you
saw an op-ed
that purportedly written by Amber Heard
That appeared in the Washington Post
Mr Wiggum I would like to show you
please uh what was entered previously
into evidence as plaintiff's exhibit one
uh Mr Gibson would you please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit one and your honor
uh may we please publish this to the
jury as it's been previously oh it is
thank you
um Mr Wiggum have you ever seen this
document before
what is it
I believe it's the
uh opinionated op-ed uh in the
Washington Post that Miss heard uh wrote
Mr Wiggum when did you first see Miss
heard's op-ed in the Washington Post
it would have it would have been right
contemporaneous to when it came out
and Tom if you would please move ahead
to I believe the second page in
plaintiff's exhibit one
um
and drawing your attention specifically
to the third paragraph of the op-ed
misheard writes quote two years ago I
became a public figure representing
domestic abuse and I felt the full force
of our culture's wrath for women for
women who speak out unquote
what if anything what if any
understanding do you have of that
reference
that it was regarding Johnny and
their relationship
directing your attention uh Tom if we
could just move back up to the first
page of exhibit one
uh directing your attention to the title
of the article quote Amber Heard colon I
spoke up against sexual violence unquote
what if any understanding do you have of
that reference Jackson honor to relevant
what his understanding is I'll load
that was uh
that was rather shocking I remember
because it was the first time I'd heard
an allegation of sexual abuse
and against whom was the allegation of
sexual abuse objection
I'll sustain the objection next question
Mr Wiggum directing your attention to
the fifth paragraph of plaintiff's
exhibit one
misheard writes quote I had the rare
vantage point of seeing in real time how
institutions protect men accused of
abuse unquote to what does that refer
Ence objection next question Mr Gibson
if you would please take down
plaintiff's exhibit one
Mr Wiggum how if at all was Miss heard's
op-ed different from other articles
about the couple's relationship
objection honor calls for hearsay
Foundation all right Mr Wiggum have you
seen other articles in the course of
your duties as Mr Depp's agent about
Amber Heard and Johnny Depp objection
Foundation out loud
thank you
um how if it all was the op-ed different
from other articles you had read about
the Johnny Depp Amber Heard relationship
it you know it was a first person
account coming from the victim uh it's
an extremely impactful
impactful and in a good or bad way
on
with respect to Johnny it was it was
catastrophic because it was coming from
you know a first person account it was
not from a journalist if it was not from
someone observing it was from someone
saying this happened to me
Mr Wiggum between December 18 2018.
the date of the op-ed in October 2020
did Mr Depp perform in any Studio films
sorry could you could you just repeat
the dates between December 18 2018 which
is the date that Miss heard's op-ed
appeared in October 2020
to what extent if any did Mr Depp
perform in any Studio films
zero no Studio phones
how if at all did Miss heard's op-ed
impact Mr Depp's ability to land roles
in studio films between December 2018
and October 2020. objection your honor
calls for hearsay foundation and expert
I'll sustain that objection next
are you near the end Mr Chew I just want
to make sure okay I've got probably five
minutes okay that's good good uh What
effect if any did the op-ed have on the
release of minamata the indie film you
mentioned earlier calls for years
Facebook hearsay speculations
sure yes Ron
foreign
what happened Mr Wiggum after the op-ed
but before October 2020
with respect to minimata
so the op-ed
came out in decem
ber right as we were going on Christmas
break and uh minamata was supposed to
start in January and I I remember
it was very very difficult to keep
minamata together the financing became
shaky the
the budget had to come down Johnny's fee
came down in order to save the movie
Tom if you would please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 584 and we're not
asking to publish it because it does not
come in
this is an email chain with the subject
line quote uh Johnny Depp's Jack Sparrow
won't return object to him reading
from that
the
jury
that's fine you're on a weekend
um
Mr Wiggum do you recognize this email
chain
I yes now that I'm looking at it what is
the date of this email chain
uh I think December 20th
December 20th of what year sir
all right uh December 20th of 2018.
Mr welcome Mr Wiggum directing your
attention to the middle email message on
plaintiff's exhibit 584. did you receive
this message from Christian Carino in or
about December 20th 2018 at 3 26 p.m I'm
going to object because it's a hearsay
document he's asking questions from the
hearsay document I love that question
we'll see where we go
her honor said you may answer that
question
yes I you got I see you know I see what
he's asking me
would you please explain to the jury
what the message was about objection
your honor hearsay
hearsay he's asking him to essentially
accept one approach for a moment
Tom if you could please take that down
Mr Wiggum did there come a time after
Miss heard's publication of the op-ed on
December 18 2018
but before October 2020
that you learned more about Disney's
plans about whether it would cast Mr
Depp in Pirate six
all right I'm just asking whether he
okay I'll allow that
yes
when did that happen
in 2019
what happened
go ahead
next question
what what happened in 2019 with respect
to Disney you're learning about Disney's
plans uh whether to use Mr DAP in Pirate
six objection
yeah
what happened he said yes
I'll out what happened go ahead
it became clear they were going in a
different direction
when did you learn that Disney was going
in a different direction and no longer
planned to use Mr Depp in Pirate six
early 2000s
and
team
who is Margot Robbie
she's a fantastic actress she's a client
a CAA what if anything did you learn
about the role Margot Robbie would be
playing in Pirate six
I think that culture here again I'm
going to object that all over really
objection
I I learned that they were developing a
pirate's project for her to star in
after you learned
that Disney was going in a different
direction in early 2019 and no longer
planned to use Mr Depp
did you to what extent did you reach out
to Jerry Bruckheimer or Sean Bailey
it does not yarn I'm overruled out loud
thank you
a lot
did you reach out to Mr Bruckheimer and
Mr Bailey jointly or separately
separately
what if anything was the result of your
Outreach to Mr buckheimer and Mr Bailey
hearsay
I'm just asking what the result was
all right I'll sustain the objection
next question
after your Outreach to Mr Bailey and or
strike that
was your Outreach to Mr Bruckheimer and
Mr Bailey successful objective
I successfully made contact with them
but I was not successful in
rescuing
pirates for Johnny
when was the last time
you discussed Mr Depp's role in Pirate
six with Jerry Bruckheimer
Sean Bailey or anyone else at Disney
I'm going to object your honor on
hearsay yeah overall
2019 I believe
in addition to Pirate six did Mr Depp
lose other films between December 2018
and October 2020 because of Miss hurt's
op-ed objection I'll sustain the
objection
in it in addition to Pirate sex
did Mr Depp lose any other films between
December 2018 and October 20.
I don't think he testified that he lost
pirate six second of all she's now
contradicting the witness's testimony
which is inappropriate
good answer question
yes
after after the op-ed it was
impossible to get him a studio film
which is what we normally would have
been focused on in that time period
Mr Wiggum to what extent
did covid
or strike that to what extent if any did
kovat did covid impact Mr Depp's
opportunities prior to October 2020.
I think it had an effect on on Johnny
like uh like other actors to some degree
but
we we were still doing business
especially on behalf of you know
bigger stars that green films and so
what was happening was we would we would
close deals or you know put together a
movie and then just set the start date
for whenever people could get together
and actually shoot the movie
Mr Wiggum in your many interactions with
Mr Depp have you ever seen him angry
objection your honor it's leading
a sustain us the leading in your many
interaction thank you your honor in your
many interactions with Mr Depp to what
extent if any have you ever seen him
lose his temper
I never have actually to what extent if
any has Mr Depp ever raised his voice in
your presence
no he never has Mr Wiggum to what extent
have you ever seen Mr Depp engage in any
violence
never
Mr Wiggum other than misheard are you
aware of any other woman who has ever
accused Mr Depp of physical abuse
objection
thank you Ron uh thank you Mr Wiggum all
right I'll pass the witness all right Mr
wiggin we'll do cross-examination in
about 15 minutes I'm going to take a
15-minute morning recess okay sir all
right ladies and gentlemen we'll go
ahead and take our morning recess do not
discuss the case with anybody and don't
do any outside research okay
Mr Wiggum what I'll do is put you in the
lobby and then I'll you won't see
anything in about 15 minutes I'll bring
it back okay
all right thank you
all right at this point we'll just come
back at noon okay all right all right
thank you
you ready for the jury okay
thank you
excuse me
okay
all right Mr wigman can you hear me okay
all right as soon as you ask him his
first question he should pop up there
he'll come up there yeah
cross-examination thank you your honor
Mr Wiggum you testified that you closed
a deal
for Mr debb for pirate six with him
acting as Jack Sparrow do you recall
that testimony
uh yes
Mr William could you do me a favor and
just count from one to five for me so I
can get you on my big screens here
sure one two three four five
there we go okay thank you sir I
appreciate I'm sorry
but in fact Mr Wiggum it's not true that
Mr Depp ever had a contract with Disney
for pirate six isn't that correct
can you explain that question or that
position have you ever seen a contract
that provides for Mr Depp to play pirate
six
I to I tested my knowledge my memory
myself and my partner posed an optional
picture deal for the amount of money of
what that
picture would be for Johnny and you
would you would make sure to have that
in writing wouldn't you
you know that would normally go through
legal counsel in terms of
the codification of it do you have any
explanation for why there exists nothing
no piece of paper nothing suggesting
that Mr Depp ever
had a deal with Disney for pirate six a
Texan lack of foundation compound oh I
love it
so uh I often
close
when I was an agent we would work on
many deals where I actually wouldn't see
contracts they were verbal in nature and
then you know especially on on optional
pictures just so there was an
understanding of what the money would be
so do you have an explanation why there
is not even a piece of paper not an
email not a text not a piece not a
document nothing that suggests that Mr
Depp is going to be in Pirate six as
Jack Sparrow objection asked and
answered I I don't believe it was so
overruled Ella
uh I mean it draws me to my opinion it
wouldn't necessarily be alarming because
that would be a conversation usually to
understand Disney's going to want to
know are we on the same
uh are we on the same uh page about what
the money's going to be and most of that
conversation if I remember correctly was
also
with one of Johnny's lawyer at the time
okay and and so you you have so Johnny's
lawyer was discussing this but there's
no document
do you have an explanation for that you
well you may know better than me if
there is a document but that that was
Jake Bloom you know at the time I
believe a memory certainly correct all
right but you would it be fair to say
that you have never seen a document that
provides that Mr Depp was going to be in
Pirate six
it would be fair to say that it was
consistent with a lot of the
conversations that I would have on
behalf of big stars where it was verbal
and there was an understanding of what
the what the deal was going to be Mr
Wiggum if you could answer my question
harassment he did answer the question
you want to ask your question thank you
sure
Judy can you repeat the question sorry
Judy can you read that back thank you
all right
document that provides that Mr Jeff was
going to be the empire
it would be fair to say that I have not
seen a document on Pirates now just so
you know I don't Mr Wiggum Mr Wiggum I
don't I don't need you to give me extra
I just want you to answer mine I just
want to know have you ever seen a
document that says Mr Depp is going to
be in Pirate six
I I only to fully answer the question
though I think there's there's some
cards that's an easy yes or no have you
seen a document
technically I I perhaps have because it
connects to all the other Pirates films
it's just a modification of a new
document so I I have not seen 22.5
million written on a page you're correct
about that okay now you in fact uh had
discussions back in 2016 and 2017 with
Mr Bailey Sean Bailey you talked about
him a little bit ago right
and and and you also had discussions
with Jerry Bruckheimer in 2016 and 2017
correct
yes about Mr debb potentially being in
Pirate six correct
and then you and then you had
discussions in 2018 with Mr Bailey and
he was quite non-committal about whether
Mr Depp would be in Pirate six correct
objection hearsay that's fine all right
okay given that he was able to uh
sustain us to hear say it is here all
right so you so you determined Mr Wiggum
that by the fall of 2018
it was very likely that Mr Depp was not
going to be in Pirate six is that
correct
it's a two-pronged answer my perspective
because there was really two individuals
involved in that decision I would say
Jerry Bruckheimer and Sean Bailey Jerry
Bruckheimer in the fall of 2018 really
wanted Johnny and that
next film and Sean was non-committal as
you said and Mr Berkheimer made it clear
to you that Mr Bailey was the one who
gets to decide because he's Disney right
ultimately and he also wanted to be the
tip of the spear to really try to
convince Sean okay now
thank you
thank you
do you recall having your deposition
taken on January 20 2021
okay yes ma'am with you okay can you
pull that up Michelle please thank you
I'm going to ask you to turn to page 44
and Mr Wiggum you were under oath at the
time of this deposition correct
correct yes yes line ten
this is Page 44 line 10.
the question do you recall approximately
when in 2018
you inferred from Mr your discussion
with Mr Bailey that the likelihood of Mr
Depp being in Pirate six was knock high
or was going away
and your answer at that time was if
memory serves me the latter part of 2018
Maybe
question when you say ladder is that any
time from August to December or what are
you thinking answer I would say fall you
know maybe you know October November
December in that area do you recall
giving that testimony under oath at that
time
I I do now that I see it yes okay
in fact they were quite a few things
going on earlier in 2018 that might have
had a bit of an a impact on Mr Depp's
reputation would you agree
if you it might help if you refresh your
recollection sure sure but and before I
go there though I think you said that
the reason it was so catastrophic for Mr
Depp for the op-ed was because it was a
first person account
of Johnny right
do you remember saying that
yes okay wasn't it a first person to
count when Ms heard filed for the tro
in 2016.
so that that would have predated any
relationship I had to Johnny so I had no
knowledge of that okay so you don't know
whether it was catastrophic then
it I I if you're asking me my opinion on
on something I don't know I can form an
opinion right now uh it's a work
document and
probably a little different than an
op-ed in the Washington Post
um but I would agree it's not a now that
I'm
forming an opinion that it's not a great
headline for sure when you read the
op-ed did you read it online or did you
read it in the actual post paper
well let's pull up plaintiff's exhibit
two
does this refresh your recollection
very hard for me to see it is that is
that just the paper can we we're going
to try to scroll in a little bit more
again just you can help me I is that the
paper yes article yes that's the
Washington Post
so
what's the question sorry do you does
this help refresh your recollection of
whether you saw it in print or whether
you saw it online
it does not but I'll tell you that I did
not typically
pick up the Washington Post you know
okay and so while we're sitting if you
can just for a second uh you're saying
that then two years ago I became whoops
I better not do that
clear that one then two years ago I
became a public figure representing
domestic abuse that's this first person
from Ms heard that's catastrophic for Mr
Depp is that your testimony
my testimony is that it reads like a
victim statement from someone involved
and the recipient and it became a yes a
bit of a
death nail catastrophic thing for Mr
Depp in the Hollywood Community all
right well let's go to let's pull up
defendants exhibit 99
now there was in fact
an article published in the Sun
newspaper by Dan Wooten the
editor-in-chief
on April 27 2018 do you recall that
now that I'm looking at it does that
that refreshes your recollection and in
fact this article
calls Mr Depp a wife beater does it not
objection hearsay
I'll allow it for them
uh you know what I can't I can't see the
print even with these glasses but uh
all right well we'll I'll take your word
for it
well the the title here is how can JK
Rowling be genuinely happy casting wife
beater Johnny Depp in the new Fantastic
Beast film objection here
I love that
yeah
okay
you're and I'd like to move the
admission of this exhibit I I think at
this point it's not offered to prove the
truth of the matter asserted but it's
going to offer he's testified to
comparisons of other articles he he's
he's testifying to the impact of the
op-ed I think it's In fairness we should
be able to put this in and be able to
make the comparisons it's clearly
hearsayer yeah
sustain the objection okay well let's go
to
the third page now let's go to the
fourth page so it has
A5 I think is what I'm trying to get to
so it says paragraph seven
so do you recall that it says in here uh
objection here save on it
Mr Wiggum
the article also had pictures did it not
I don't recall do you recall whether it
had a picture of Ms heard
Jackson hearsayer on it I love that
can we go to
the eighth page
I'm showing you the picture right now
does that refresh your recollection your
honor uh hearsay lack of foundation yeah
out loud
it it doesn't speak to my impression of
when I read it or how I read it but I
see the photo yes ma'am all right and in
fact it shows bruises on it doesn't it
on Ms heard's face Jackson lack of
foundation
overruled
so that would be what I think yes okay
now Mr Depp
filed a lawsuit
against the Sun newspaper and against
Dan Wooten for this article correct
I believe so June 13 2018
let's pull up one five nine nine
defendants 1599
does this refresh your recollection
Jackson here say your honor
I'm just for refreshing my collection
out loud
uh
uh just so I understand the question
you're asking does it refresh a memory
that Johnny files against the sun yes
and Dan Wooten
on June 13 2018
sure okay now that I'm looking at it all
right and he did so in the UK in the
high court of justice correct
I believe so yeah you would know better
than I okay and if we can just turn to
page nine and do you recall that Mr Depp
alleged that that article had caused him
serious harm to his personal and
professional reputation
objection hearsay calls for speculation
no I don't recall I can ask you to take
a look at paragraph 11.
and let me see if I need new glasses
okay thank you very much
is there a way to even make that screen
bigger on mine I wish I was at better
glasses more technologically they can
make it a little bigger but I think
that's about as far as I'm going to try
to highlight it here so that that might
help you a little bit let me switch the
color but
so do you recall that Mr Depp alleged
that the article by in the Sun newspaper
by Dan Wooten had caused serious harm to
the claimant's personal and professional
reputation
if you're asking me I don't recall it I
was not involved in that case at all uh
I'm able to read
what's in front of me but you don't
recall it and you don't recall if that
had any impact on on Disney in 2018.
objection asked an answer I'll sustain
the objection next question all right do
you recall that Mr Depp also alleged
that he was caused significant distress
and embarrassment by the publication of
that article
no that I don't recall that okay
I I see that because I just was not
involved in that case all right my
memory of that was it was a a tabloid so
and the lawyers were hit all right
Michelle you can take that down thank
you now there was a trial in the UK was
there not on Mr Depp's claims of libel
against Dan Wooten and the Sun
so and it was in July of 2020 was it not
I don't remember the date actually all
right and what it lasted three weeks do
you recall that
I don't but I'll take your word for it
do you recall there being an enormous
amount of publicity surrounding that
trial
objection calls for speculation lack of
foundation he said he did thank you I'm
sorry Mr Wiggum you said you did recall
that ask and answered
I'll love it
I remember there being suppressed around
it yes ma'am okay and in fact uh do you
recall that Mr Depp gave testimony for
four days
not specifically I don't do you recall
that Ms heard gave testimony for four
days
I I don't recall any specific specific
memory of who testified for how long or
any any details within the case do you
recall there being many many witnesses
testifying at that case on that case
I think I'd revert to my answer just now
okay and the press that surrounded that
case do you recall it being
focusing on things like Mr Debb's drug
and alcohol use
same answer do you recall there being
the video the kitchen video being shown
repeatedly objection your honor may we
approach
I think my last question was do you
recall there being a lot of publicity
surrounding Mr Depp's alcohol and drug
use
I think I answered that right that's
right I was on the video the kitchen
video do you recall there being that the
kitchen video being played pretty
repeatedly in the Press
no I don't do you recall
a lot of pictures of Ms heard reflecting
bruises Cuts injuries
I I think just to be clear I don't
recall anything that was going on within
the case I was always consumed with
next film and TV opportunities and that
was being handled by the lawyers
my memory
call
just have a couple more to ask you on
this do you recall there being
allegations of at least 14 incidents of
domestic violence against Ms heard in
that trial
same answer now could we bring up
exhibit number one again plaintiffs
now Mr Wiggum do you know who wrote
Amber Heard I spoke up against sexual
violence and faced our culture's wrath
this has to change
you're talking about the title yes
I wouldn't say that I to me it I would
have assumed it was misheard
you assume but you don't know do you
I do not okay and were you aware that
there were also three pleaded incidents
of sexual violence in the UK trial
against misheard by Mr Depp
no ma'am okay
now your testimony is you can take that
down no thank you
your testimony is that
since some point
in 2020
Mr Depp has not had any uh more movie
opportunities is that correct
since sorry
repeat the date when is the last time Mr
Depp had a movie opportunity
the last film that he showed
through the best of my memory all right
and in fact do you know whether the
uh the the article that was in the UK
the ensuing lawsuit that was brought by
Mr debb and the ensuing trial and all
the publicity do you know whether that
had any impact on Mr Depp's career
objection compound
do you know whether the collection of
all of those items I just listed had an
impact on Mr Depp's career
if remind me of the dates that you're
asking about
so so the answer I I take it is no you
don't know correct
I I'm just trying to make sure I give
you a correct answer so I understand the
question you referenced after 2020. okay
the article
was April of 2018.
the lawsuit was June of 2018.
the trial was July of 2020.
what opportunities has Mr Depp had since
July 2020
since July 2020
he has not done a film
thank you I have no further questions
all right redirect
good afternoon again Mr Wiggum uh do you
recall Ms bretahof asked you
questions about whether you ever
actually saw a document containing the
22 and a half million dollar deal for Mr
Depp for pirate six do you recall that
I do and do you recall when you were
trying to answer her question you said
you needed a little more context you
recall that
yes and would you please now provide the
jury that context so they can have a
fuller understanding of what your what
your testimony is
so often on a franchise movie when
you're dealing with big stars and you're
talking about future optional pictures
uh you engage
at the high level uh meaning the
president or the top of the studio to
get an understanding of what that deal
is going to going to be they then get
papered typically when I say papered
amended because it's like it's based on
the same contract usually that's been in
existence and it would get
sometimes we don't see paperwork or get
paperwork until the film is happening
and
Mr Wiggum on a similar line
Miss bretahof to ask you some questions
about whether after this deal was done
it was starting to Trend badly with
respect to Disney and not so and and
what and still well with respect to Mr
Bruckheimer in the fall of 2018 do you
remember that testimony
I do
when was it that Disney made the final
decision as to whether Mr Depp would be
Empire six
you know sustain the objection I'll
sustain the objection next question
Mr wiggin it may have been trending
badly
as of that time but Disney had not gone
in
in the other direction correct
earlier
earlier was two days after
the op-ed
and and I was saying that Disney had
never
said that Johnny would not be in the
film as of that date and
my
it was my testimony is the exact same as
the deposition which is it was trending
badly in the late fall on behalf of
Disney but I was the Jerry Bruckheimer
and I were lobbying to make it happen
and so we had hope
and it became clear to me in early 2019
that it was over
thank you very Mr thank you very much Mr
Wiggum no further questions all right
thank you is this witness subject to
recall
yes your honor all right Mr Windham this
is your subject to recall you're still
subject to the rule on Witnesses so you
cannot discuss your testimony with
anybody and you cannot watch any of the
trial okay sir
all right but you're free for today
thank you all right thank you thank you
all right your next Witness
your honor before we call the next
witness may we approach briefly okay
sure
do we have a
lot
you selling square or affirm testified
previously in this case the penalty of
law yes
good how you doing sir good afternoon
you can sit down sir that's fine
good afternoon Mr Marks uh good
afternoon would you please State your
fold name for the record
Richard Edward marks and Mr Marks where
do you live I live in Hollywood
would you tell us a little bit about
your educational background sir
I'm I'm a product of the
um
public school system in Los Angeles
and I went to UCLA undergraduate and I'm
a graduate of the UCLA School of Law
when did you graduate from UCLA School
of Law I graduated in
1973 and I've been an officer of the
courts since then almost 50 years
where do you work
I work at my own Law Firm Richard Marks
and Associates
what is Richard Marx and Associates
uh it is a transactional entertainment
Law Firm and we represent individuals
writers directors actors books
but authors but mainly we represent
producers who are developing a product
if you will to be produced and then
exploited on television features
streaming things like that
when you say a transactional law firm
what do you mean by that
uh what I do is make deals they're
transactions I'm a deal guy so my whole
practice all these decades has been
about getting to yes how do you make a
deal and then how do you get it
documented so people sign it and then
are able it's clear enough that it can
be administered and people can know what
to do after you've made the deal
[Music]
specifically what types of clients do
you work with
well as I said
I work with all kinds of clients but the
the my bigger clients and the bulk of my
practice is representing producers who
produce they develop and they produce
content for exploitation
yeah I've been working for a long time
with
ITV which is a a huge British company
with Worldwide
reach in entertainment they produce
the voice love Island and right now I've
done all the development legal work on a
mini series that's about to shoot in
France and the England starring Michael
Douglas as Benjamin Franklin it's based
on a novel that we optioned I helped
them option years ago then scripts were
written for the eight hours then Michael
Douglas was engaged the director was
engaged and I do all those contracts and
that's ITV
um another one of my uh big clients is
Village Roadshow they're an Australian
company they
they partner with Warner Brothers and
they produce movies like Matrix
Aquaman Scooby-Doo uh right now I am
working on a television series for them
doing the legal production and and
before that it was development the
production legal work on a reboot of the
old college bowl uh show where two
colleges come together with teams and
answer questions and and here they're
going to win scholarships and the hosts
are Peyton Manning and Eli Manning so
that's currently what I'm working on for
Village Road Show
any other clients and I would say my my
third big client is a company called uh
media rights MRC
and they they produce movies and and TV
shows recently I've I've done a lot of
work for them uh they are finishing up a
a mini series that I'm doing the legal
work on for Apple starring Billy crudup
uh we just finished a mini series for
them called terminal list with Chris
Pratt uh that's for Amazon
uh and and we recently finished
a mini series doing the legal deal
making for MRC
um on a show called The shrink next door
which is aired uh it
started Will Ferrell and Paul Rudd
and then I like you know I can't leave
out uh my longest client which is the
producers of uh Bosch uh for uh Amazon
uh it's got to be nine ten years ago
when we went into Amazon they had never
produced a series
and we negotiated a deal for uh Michael
Conley's book series uh and uh we cast
Titus well over as Bosch they wouldn't
order a series they would only order a
pilot and
now uh in the next few days
what I call the eighth season but which
is the first season of the spin-off will
uh be available on IMBd TV instead of on
Amazon but Amazon owns IMDb TV
uh and um and we're in right now writing
the uh the ninth season so I've had this
long run with this uh one particular
series
can you tell the jury a little bit about
the types of deals that you work on for
these clients
foreign
well when you think of um of a of a
series or emotion picture
and you see the credits there's hundreds
of of credits there and everyone of
those people you have to make a deal
with them and you have to pay for it so
that they they sign it and you know what
to pay them and what what is there a
guild involved a union uh you know what
are their services and
um what I do is
all of that Soup To Nuts uh many times
sometimes I work with in-house counsel
or other attorneys and we split up the
work but basically uh you know you want
to produce a movie or a show you you
might option A book I do that dealing
you might hire a writer then you might
get a director then then a line producer
a upm for A.D then you start hiring your
cast then you start making location
deals then you start renting equipment
and props and getting releases for
photos you might show or for people who
might end up on camera
and then when you're done shooting
you're making deals for
merchandising and deals with
Distributors and uh in the old days it
was might have been for a DVD or for
merchandising a doll
and so it's really
what I do is make deals and all deals uh
I've been doing it for almost 50 years
but they're all the same they have
elements of time money credit rights and
perks
and I have approached deals that way so
that I've
made myself relevant when I started out
there were three networks and big
studios
and attorneys said well I'm a TV lawyer
I'm a feature lawyer I just said I'm a
transactional lawyer and so I've been
able to adapt and make deals with
Netflix quibby YouTube uh you know you
name it I've I've made deals I mean I
recently made a deal with uh Hellman's
mayonnaise for an actress who is going
to be an influencer for them on the web
and it was you know hype it's a good
Payday for this actress but
that's the way I look at deals I'm a
deal maker and that's my practice
you testify the
um have been working in the
entertainment industry almost 50 years
how did you get started in the
entertainment industry
I got started in the entertainment
industry by being born in Hollywood and
it's our it's our town industry if you
will
and I've always been interested in it
and when I went to UCLA I took all the
film classes there were
uh and when I went to UCLA law school it
was by Design because number one I
couldn't afford the the big law school
so UCLA was a public school it was
virtually free I went to UCLA law school
because if you want to practice
entertainment law in Hollywood
those you go to UCLA or USC those are
the the schools where you kind of create
your contacts and your your network
uh and at UCLA they had some of the best
professors who taught entertainment Law
related subjects so I took copyright
trademark uh entertainment contracts if
you will I took Everything Entertainment
related
um
and and that's how I kind of built the
foundation for then my afterlaw school
career
what did you do after you graduated from
Law School
well I um I wanted to do entertainment
and transaction law but
I realized I could earn a little bit
more money if I went into entertainment
litigation uh suing over copyrights and
trademarks and so I took uh the highest
paying job out of that I could get out
of law school and was uh in 1973 and I I
did I P litigation disputes over
copyrights trademarks uh disputes over
rights things like that and I was a
low-level litigator
um doing depositions or motions uh
certainly not sitting at the you know
examining Witnesses except it might be
in a deposition
and and I and I did that uh for about it
was my first year out of Law School
what did you do after that
well after that I I kind of made a
decision that uh being a litigator
wasn't for me
uh that I wanted to make deals that I
wanted my career to be about getting to
yes
and that involved a lot of uh uh you
know conflict sometimes but the goal was
to get to yes so that um both parties
could work together because the goal was
working together and creating the TV
show not making the deal the deal makers
had to step away so that you closed the
deal and then people could live with
that deal and um so I went to a a
transactional law firm and um uh I was
there a couple years and and I made
deals
what kind of projects did you work on
when you transitioned into that uh deal
making role
well this is um you know uh
mid 1970s and this law firm uh uh was
taught if you will and some of my
classmates were there that's how I got
the job I had to take a cut in pay to go
there uh and
um I I'll never forget I'm the second
chair attorney
in a big conference room at Fox and
we're trying to close a deal for our
young client George Lucas to make a film
called Star Wars a
western Space movie and fox would not
give us the budget or the salary he
wanted
and this is the God's honest truth we
said okay give us the merchandising
and famously they gave us the
merchandising because they didn't think
there was value there
and that's how much our business has
changed
while I was at uh that my first
transactional firm we also worked for a
client his name is Sylvester Stallone
he his claim to fame is that he was a
character actor but he had written a
script that all the major Stars wanted
to play they wanted to play the role
Rocky and he said I will not sell this
script unless I play Rocky and no one
was happy about that and the deal we
made was uh he got to play the role but
it was a very low budget and he hardly
had a dressing room he hardly had any
perks he wasn't happy about it but we
were able to make up for that in the
deals for Rocky two three
and and and that's the type of deals it
was we at that entertainment
transactional firm we weren't
representing
um
uh major companies if you will we were
representing artists uh writers
directors Talent like I'm uh you know
individuals we weren't representing the
companies I do now like ITV or Village
Road Show
how long were you at that law firm
I was at that firm uh for um
a couple years
what did you do after that
after that I made a decision that
um I I
wanted to go in-house where the
full-time business was
making a you know product and
I was very tied to production and uh and
I was I wanted to move away from law
firms at that moment and my first
in-house job was for the Ziegler
discount agency
which was one of the Premier literary
agencies in town we we represented
writers and books and the states of
books and at that time in
late 70s early 80s if you wanted to hire
a writer or a book
or option of book
there were three places you went he went
to Swifty which he's kind of famous
swiffy lazar's Oscar parties or you went
to uh Swanee H.L Swanson or you went to
Ziggy and I worked for Ziggy
did you work for any other companies in
in house capacity as a deal maker
oh yeah yeah I I you know with Ziggy uh
we made deals for the book The Princess
Bride we we did a lot of we worked for
William Goldman who that was his book
and his screenplay and uh you know it
was a fabulous experience but that firm
was bought by
um uh ICM a much bigger agency and then
I moved to Paramount that's what I where
I next went and at Paramount I um uh was
the attorney on the series cheers and
the series Family Ties which was the the
break for the the young son Michael J
fox
um
and then I did something because I have
never
said I'm just a TV lawyer I'm a deal
maker I get to yes
and it's sort of unheard of but I moved
from Network television doing the deals
for church and family times I moved to
features of Paramount
uh because you can earn a little more
money and features uh and I was married
and uh I I had a child
and and it features I was assigned to do
the development and production work for
a producer who's in this case Jerry
Bruckheimer uh and um
and I also uh
served they had an overall deal with
Eddie Murphy so I I did his the legal
work and his films like Beverly Hills
Cop
uh Coming to America things like that
and I and I was at Paramount about four
years
where'd you go after Paramount
uh after Paramount I got this
opportunity to head up business and
legal Affairs in the feature division
for Jerry Weintraub Studio Jerry was
famous at the time for Karate Kid at
Ocean's 11 and
he represented
you know Elvis and Frank Sinatra in
music and John Denver but this was his
Motion Picture company and uh and I uh
was in features
and um
uh at we we made a film called Troop
Beverly Hills which is starring Shelley
Long
uh we made another film the big blue we
acquired a film Library he was
positioning himself to be a major
company until he went bankrupt and that
was one of his only failures
where'd you go after that uh after Jerry
Weintraub I went to Disney and I filled
in for a year for the head of legal and
features who was on maternity leave and
taking a family leave and so I uh headed
up legal on films like Dick Tracy
Madonna was in that uh
Rocketeer and other live-action film but
what I really remember about my time at
Disney is they were revamping the um
animation department and they wanted to
make a different kind of Disney animated
film
and part of it in the old days Disney
animated films
um the um the voices weren't advertised
they weren't the stars of the movie
Disney was the star or Dumbo was a star
but the voices were hardly known
and we broke that mold and it was the
the first deal where we paid real money
to someone to do a voice was a deal I
made with
Robin Williams to voice Aladdin and it
changed the whole history of Disney and
feature animation I worked on Beauty and
the Beast and and it was a it was a
tremendous experience to be involved
with them
after you worked at Disney did you
continue to fill in-house uh deal making
roles yeah I continued my in-house Road
even in the world that I could see was
consolidating and it was going to be
more and more difficult to stay in-house
um after Disney I went to a company
called media Home Entertainment
and they put up money for films
and for their investment they got the
VHS cassette rights so the media home
entertainment was one of the producers
investors in the Nightmare and Elm
Street series and blue velvet and what
they got was the right to sell video
cassettes they also
manufactured and sold the Jane Fonda
videos or the NFL videos and
it was a it was a great business except
the studios realized are we crazy why
are we letting another company sell
video we should keep that in-house and
so I was not only had a legal but I was
on the board of directors and we sold
the company to to Fox so that they could
take in the assets and eliminate a a
competitor
where'd you go after that
um
after media home entertainment I went to
a company called Kushner lock it was
very it was a time in the business there
were hundreds of independent producing
companies because the networks couldn't
produce for themselves there were laws
preventing it
and Christian Locke we produced um
Pinocchio with Jonathan Taylor Thomas we
produced a small movie called freeway it
was Reese Witherspoon's one of her first
roles and
it was um I was there for eight years it
was a good long run uh until uh they
as all those independent companies
ultimately did not all most they would
he they went bankrupt after eight years
what did you do after that
uh now you can see I'm still chasing the
in-house uh world I went to a company
nalvana they were a
a Canadian animation company but they
had this big office in La I headed up
business legal we manufactured made
produced
animated uh television series like Care
Bears and and Merchandising also uh
Babar big bear little bear uh all sorts
of animated subjects and Merchandising
deals and cartoons if you will and
then that Canadian company closed the LA
office moved back to Canada I didn't
want to move back to Canada and so my
last in-house situation I went to a
universal network television and I did
business and legal Affairs on
uh just shoot me a television series uh
a series starring Josh Brolin called Mr
Sterling was kind of patterned on Mr
Smith Goes to Washington
um and at the same time I was at uh
Universal network television I I
consulted uh with uh Nickelodeon
features and um
I um uh I I I helped them sort of build
out their their feature uh
products
they were on the Paramount lot I had
been at Paramount for a long time and we
worked on Films such as SpongeBob the
animated film
and then when when that Consulting ended
and NBC came in and bought Universal
that you know ended my my job at
Universal and I made the decision I
would go back and be a a lawyer at a law
firm what types of work were you doing
when you went back to the law firms
when I went back to the law firm I um I
did
a lot of you know I worked on their
clients uh and uh I I helped a financier
Robert Silverman in effect by the
American Idol brand I worked with uh
Barry Gordy's company
trying to turn some of his world into
theatrical plays I worked with the Nat
King Cole estate trying to to do things
so it was a lot of reality I remember I
worked with Walt J Walter Thompson and
they um
they were
in effect creating advertising
opportunity branding and then the one
that sticks to my mind is I I help you
know George Foreman Market things so
that he made a deal to be the face of a
thing called the George Foreman grill
and
and it was a it was a it's a good
practice
Mr Mark she testified that you now are
at a law firm called Richard Marx and
Associates when did you start that firm
well after the firm I just told you
about was called Greenberg trial rig
it's a large International firm I moved
to a firm called the point media in
um
2006 and I was there for 14 years
doing much the same work that I do now
and then in 2020 right at the start of
the pandemic I went out on my own
informed Richard Marx and Associates
over the course of your career what if
any changes have you observed in the
deal making space in the entertainment
industry
well
before I got involved in the business
most deals for writers were how much
money per week and how many weeks
when when I got into the business it was
already more complicated but through my
decades all that's happened has gotten
more and more complicated still the
Essential Elements of time money credit
uh
uh perks uh money uh whatever but it's
gotten more complicated you had to deal
with merchandising you had to deal with
sequels you had to deal with all sorts
of derivative Works video games you name
it uh you know publicity promotion it
all expanded so that making a deal
that might have been you know simple
30 years before now was a major
production and uh you know lawyers
became integral you couldn't get it do a
deal without someone who was going to
dive into the the boilerplate and make
sure that it was right
your honor I remember which gears a
little
bit
now for lunch if you could approach us
for a moment
thank you
foreign
before we take lunch plaintiff would
move in Mr Marks as an expert in the
entertainment industry all right any
objections all right so moved all right
ladies and gentlemen we'll go ahead and
take our our lunch then uh please do not
talk too many anybody and don't do any
outside research we'll see you back in
an hour okay thank you
Mr Mark if you just stay there for a
second sir
stay there for a second
sir
since you're in the middle of your
testimony you cannot talk to anybody
about your testimony at this time
including any lawyers or Mr death okay
sir all right all right we'll be back
and we'll be back at let's make it two
o'clock okay all right thank you
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
no
thank you
excuse me
popping my mic
popping the mic too close to it
was I
foreign
forward
all right how you doing sir all right
are you ready for the jury
okay
foreign
thank you Hunter
foreign
Mr Marks what work were you asked to do
in this case
uh I was asked to
bring my years of experience in the
entertainment industry
uh and look at the the damage that the
op-ed of
2018
created in Johnny Depp's career and his
life and his reputation
what work did you do to determine
whether Mr Depp's reputation had been
damaged by the op-ed
well again I I view the op-ed and the
Fallout through almost 50 years in the
business and what I did was I read the
pleadings in the case the deposition
transcripts the Articles uh
uh the pleadings
all of the the
paperwork in this case which is
voluminous
based on the analysis you've done and
your expertise in the entertainment
industry have you formed any opinions in
this case
yes what generally speaking what is your
opinion my general opinion is that the
op-ed uh
damaged uh uh Mr Depp created a a
canceled situation if you will uh harmed
his reputation and his ability to get
work and yeah Hollywood industry hold on
sir yes
I thought that could we approach sure
Mr Marks do you have experience working
with companies looking to engage actors
to Market or advertise their products
yes and what's that experience
well virtually every company I I work
for uh they are engaging actors to
advertise their products
most of the time those products are TV
shows or streaming series or feature
films
that all involve products spin-offs and
derivatives and sometimes they are just
uh
products
and spokespeople getting together
but yes I have experience in in uh
hiring a star to be the face of your
product
what types of things do companies
consider when they're looking at using
actors in their marketing or advertising
well as you can imagine they consider
reputation this is a capitalist society
and they're looking to make money they
want to add value to their investment
they want actors who have reputations
that will bring eyeballs to the screen
bodies in the seats they're looking for
added value not negativity
do you have experience negotiating
agreements for actors to play a certain
role in a film
oh yes as I explained I I negotiate
deals with actors to play roles in films
and
what's the significance of the actor in
the starring role in the context of a
feature film
the um the actor in the starring role
becomes the face of the film The Product
the series
that actor is synonymous
with the product and again in hiring
that actor or actress you um uh want a
reputation that supports uh the value
that you've spent on creating the
product
uh
you might say the Pirates of the
Caribbean is Johnny Depp and vice versa
that's this importance of hiring a star
what aspects of an actor's reputation
might impact their ability to get hired
by brands or Studios
well again on the other side of the coin
yeah you um you wouldn't want to hire an
actor who has negativity uh following
them you wouldn't want to pay to
actually bring your brand down your
movie and uh
so that's very important and especially
in the The Last Five Years uh uh with
the metoo movement uh you wouldn't want
uh negativity
uh hiring an actor
Who quote unquote had been canceled
are there um is there anything in
particular that might prevent an actor
from getting hired by a brand or a
studio
well I mean we're talking about illegal
activity a criminal record but right now
uh the the Pinnacle of uh negativity uh
in Hollywood is uh being accused of
domestic abuse sexual abuse violence and
what we've seen is almost immediately
terminations and cancellations
to for for the investors to the people
who create that product to to move away
from that negativity
I think you mentioned the metoo movement
um what's your understanding of what the
metoo movement is
my understanding of the metoo movement
is that
uh
finally a society is listening to the uh
victim giving the the victim of domestic
abuse
sexual abuse the benefit of the doubt
and there has been a shift in our
society
from not doing that to now
the victim gets the benefit of the doubt
until there's too much doubt
and to me that's the metoo movement one
person can come forward and accuse
Harvey Weinstein and another person can
come forward in another and another
that's the me too part of it but they
get the benefit of the doubt whereas
in the past uh
the the victim didn't have that benefit
what impact has the metoo movement
move Hollywood conducts business
it um
in my many decades in the business
Hollywood has has changed and morphed
but
never as quickly
as to respond to the metoo movement that
started in 2017. when I started in the
business
every contract
for an actor or someone involved in the
movie had a morals Clause that you did
certain things and you could be fired
for it uh they wanted to protect their
brand
in the before the metoo movement that
moral's Clause was fading out
uh
people with leverage people said wait a
second you just can't get rid of us
because you think this or that
with the metoo movement Harvey Weinstein
Bill Cosby if you will the morals Clause
has come back and it is a demanded
feature in every uh entertainment uh
employment agreement because the studios
want that verbiage they want those
rights so that they can act quickly and
decisively
when there is a a claim
Mr Marx do you have any experience
working on a project where an actor was
accused of domestic abuse or sexual
violence yes what was that experience
I did um some of the production uh legal
work on a film called
all the money in the world uh it was
about the life of the Gettys J Paul
getting Jay Paul Getty was played by Uh
Kevin Spacey
uh he acted in the part he finished his
role he was paid and then
these metoo accusations came out
and immediately my client in conjunction
with Sony they made a decision to take
him out of the movie
uh and we have uh Christopher Plummer
was hired they re-shot all his scenes
and seamlessly cut them in uh to the
movie and if you see that all the money
in the world you won't know that Kevin
Spacey was ever in it
so I had that personal experience and
then coincidentally when that happened
I was also doing work for MRC which
produces House of Cards uh and
a very successful series and and he was
the star of it and he was immediately
cut out and everything was redone
to to get rid of the the the notion that
Hollywood would support an abuser after
the the metoo movement
um and then I because I was in the mix
of all of it I also know that Kevin
Spacey had completed another movie for
Netflix
um and unlike uh all the money in the
world they couldn't reshoot it and it
sits on the Shelf a movie about Gore
Vidal that was finished but has never
seen the LIE today
what's your understanding of why these
companies wanted Kevin Spacey removed
from those projects
can you repeat the question
what's your understanding of why these
companies wanted Kevin Spacey removed
from those projects
these companies as I've said they want
they wanted Kevin Spacey removed because
it didn't want the negativity they they
want anyone removed so that
they can get a return on their
investment in our society so that they
are not seen as being in the old
generation where women were not given
the benefit of the doubt we're a victims
were not given the benefit of the doubt
and uh
there a switch has been turned uh and
and certainly by 2017.
are there certain types of companies
that are particularly sensitive to these
kinds of allegations made by women in
light of metoo movement
well I would say
the bigger the company the bigger the
budgets
they're all sensitive
but at the Pinnacle of sensitivity are
the family friendly companies like
Disney they're particularly sensitive
not in a general way but in a very
specific way
Mr Marks are you familiar with the op-ed
misheard published in the Washington
Post on December 18 2018. yes what's
your understanding of how that op-ed was
received in Hollywood
my understanding of how that op-ed was
received in Hollywood I'm sorry sir is
this his personal understanding his
expert understanding it it seems like if
it's a personal understanding it's not
relevant
I'm asking Mr March based on his nearly
50 years
objection thank you
uh
as I've said before I am a member of the
Hollywood Community
that op-ed
uh for the first time is in a a
mainstream publication called The
Washington Post this is a flagship
uh Journal if you will of American news
we're not talking about a trade paper
we're not talking about a rag we're
talking about the Washington Post and it
it is geared to Hollywood it says two
years ago when I was getting my divorce
Amber Heard is saying uh I I was the
abuser and you didn't Hollywood you you
stood up for my uh abuser not for sure
now he's mischaracterizing the document
I think he's he's expressing his
understanding of how that was personal
overall objection
what I'm saying is Hollywood got the uh
the the subject matter the loud of the
of the op-ed loud and clear
Amber Heard was calling out Hollywood
for supporting uh uh since night since
2016 supporting her abuser and uh uh she
felt the wrath of Hollywood she was
calling them out to do something in the
Washington Post and
um on the eve of her biggest uh film a
big film for Hollywood the publicity
machine was in high gear there was lots
of publicity and uh news out there this
was the height of of her Fame and she
used it at that moment to call Hollywood
out they uh in my opinion as a member of
Hollywood they heard uh that plea loud
and clear uh and um uh it also got her
publicity for her movie uh you know I
don't think that that
in my perception of people in Hollywood
didn't see that as a coincidence that
date uh and um
so yeah in Hollywood I think um uh the
the message was received that she was
sending
Mr Marcus do you have an understanding
of Mr Depp's reputation in Hollywood
with respect to whether or not he's on
time to his film sets
yes what's your understanding
Hollywood has a history of putting up
with major artists and major Stars
idiosyncratic behaviors
you know we've always had uh
Divas like Marilyn Monroe who would stay
under trailer for half a day Johnny Depp
has a reputation of being Johnny Depp
and when you hire Johnny Depp you get
all of Johnny Depp and that includes
being late
and fortunately in Hollywood because of
the budgets and the and the box office
you can budget for for lateness you can
have second unit you can have other
shots uh you can you have padding in
budgets
you have insurance for for accidents but
Hollywood Knows Mr Depp's uh reputation
and uh
you know I heard someone say Hollywood
puts up with Diva and drugs uh they only
do that uh when uh it money's involved
and big stars are involved in Artistry
is involved
Mr Marx
who have an understanding of Mr Depp's
overall reputation in Hollywood prior to
the publication of the December 2018
op-ed
um
I would say that um
Johnny Depp was one of the few uh major
actors in Hollywood who managed to keep
most of his personal life personal
kept
himself uh shrouded if you will a bit
um
and his reputation you know preceded him
as a major artist in Hollywood
but what what also marked him uh in this
business is that
he
was congruent he was he was likable he
you know he he was uh uh you know one of
the one of the one of the guys and uh it
um uh I I never heard uh
any uh
complaints uh you know uh
if you will
do you have an opinion about the impact
of the publication of the op-ed on Mr
Depp's reputation in Hollywood
it's devastating it it's um it's it's
the type of claim the me too claim of
sexual violence domestic abuse that
has canceled a list of of uh of actors
uh krishnath recently I just read
something about Frank langella we know
uh
newscasters uh Les moonves ahead of ABC
CBS uh now Johnny Depp is in their ranks
it's it's devastating
thank you everyone know for the
questions all right cross-examination Mr
nadelhoff
good afternoon
um you're right in this case is 975
dollars per hour is that right
that's correct and you've Char and
you've never charged that higher rate in
any other cases isn't that right
I've I've charged near that amount but
but never that high correct that's
correct okay how much of your Char how
much have you received for this case
uh I'd have to look at my billing during
my deposition uh uh the the attorney who
deposed me asked me the same question I
said I would look it up I did during
lunch and then she never got back to it
again I don't remember how much it was
then and I don't have the figures uh now
and you don't know how many hours he
worked on this case
I would get uh again I'd be guessing and
I don't know if you want me to guess I
have a full-time transactional practice
this is a very small part of my practice
now you said you worked for Disney
uh for less than a year right I worked
for Disney about a year yeah and that
was in 1990 right
uh yes so that was about that was 32
years ago yeah okay and you worked at
Greenberg trialing from 2004 to 2006 is
that right that's correct you're leaving
was a mutual decision was it not yes
okay
um
now
Mr depsel has an endorsement deal with
uh Dior correct
I understand that yes okay and he's had
that endorsement deal since 2015 isn't
that right
uh I I believe he's had the endorsement
deal for a while and I think he still
has it right and Dior hasn't dropped Mr
Depp correct as far as I know Dior has
not dropped him all right and Mr Depp
did not have a contract for pirate six
isn't that right
as far as I know there is no contract uh
for pirate six right and all the
documents you've looked at you looked at
all the documents in this case and
you've not seen a contract for pirate
sex right
that's my memory of the documents there
was no contract for pirates and in all
the documents you looked at you didn't
see a text saying Mr Depp got the
contract for pirate six for 22.5 million
right
objection asked and answered overruled
I I didn't see paperwork on uh an
agreement for uh car uh Pirates of the
Caribbean six so not an email not a text
not any written document about pirate
six correct objection ask an answer I'll
sustain that objection next question
foreign
and you don't know one way or the other
whether Mr Depp will be in Pirates of
Caribbean six you don't have a crystal
ball is that right
objection speculation
he's an expert I love it yeah go ahead
overrule go ahead you can answer sir
well as an expert of course I don't have
a crystal ball but as an expert uh uh I
think Disney will do everything possible
to try to put him back in Pirates but
not under uh This Cloud okay yeah
you would agree that there was negative
publicity about Mr death before the
op-ed correct
yes you know that Miss heard made her
accusations public starting in May of
2016 right
yes and and Hollywood knew about that
right yes okay
and Mr Depp still had movies after May
of 2016 right
yes okay
now you would agree that there was
negative publicity about Mr Depp being
publicly drunk before the op-ed correct
there was I I agree with the proposition
that there was negative publicity before
the op-ed the op-ed was something
different
and you agree as in in 2014 there was an
article in the guardian that said
apparently drunk Johnny Depp cut off at
Hollywood film award ceremony would you
agree with that
again I I don't remember reading the the
guardian uh and I don't remember that
particular incident but I I'll take you
at your word and you were you remember
in looking through all the documents
that you saw an article that Johnny Depp
allegedly showed up drunk to movie
premiere reports today right that was in
2017.
I I I think I've testified that uh
there there is certainly Johnny Depp
behavior and and uh negativity out there
yes
and what and that a family that a family
that a family Production Studio like
Disney wouldn't want to be associated
with correct
uh again you're talking about a very
specific uh uh you know
um series of five films that earned
billions of dollars uh and there is a
line in Hollywood as I've said they'll
put up with divas and drugs to make
money uh but now we've drawn a line uh
in Hollywood at uh the um uh domestic
and sexual abuse and looking through the
documents you saw the articles in June
of 2018 that said vodka for breakfast
72-hour drug binges and spending sprees
that beggar belief you saw that
again I I know these articles exist I
know they're not in the Washington Post
I don't know what article you're
referring to who wrote it uh you know
what publication it was in but I know
that those articles exist and you'd
agree that before the op-ed Mr death had
a run of movie flops wouldn't you agree
every actor has uh you know ups and
downs Mr Depp is his career has been
decades long you would agree that in in
January of 2015 there was an article
that said Johnny Depp is on his way to
becoming the most overpaid actor in
Hollywood
again you'd have to show me the article
but I don't doubt that some commentator
trying to trade on being a smarty pants
wrote that and you'd agree that there
was another article in 2015 that says
quote has Johnny Depp become Hollywood's
biggest joke
I don't know Netflix has a whole
festival going now Netflix is a joke and
you'd agree that there is an article in
Business Insider from 2015 that says
Johnny Depp has his fifth box office
bomb in a row
if that's what it said it said are you
just going to keep reading this well I
mean this is Mr Depp's reputation that's
what you're talking about in terms of in
terms of Hollywood correct and in 2016
December of 2016 there's a quote there's
an article that says quote Johnny Depp
is Hollywood's most overpaid actor for
the second year in a row did you recall
reading that
and it was out written by the second uh
underpaid actor or and you would agree
that before the op-ed there was a
negative publicity for Mr Depp about
assassinating president Trump you agree
no I missed that one you didn't see an
article in the New York Times that said
Johnny Depp flirts with idea of trump
assassination that apologizes again
is that John Reader talks with the irony
and uh Panache and uh I don't
particularly remember that I have a lot
of stuff in front of me Disney wouldn't
want to be Disney wouldn't want to be
involved with somebody who's calling for
the assassination of the president would
it I'm sure after those articles uh
Johnny Depp was involved in major Studio
project do you know one way or the other
whether Mr Depp was involved in major
Studio Projects after June 23 2017.
uh I I I think uh again I I haven't
quoted his uh IMDb DB page to memory but
he was in um uh an animated film called
Sherlock gnomes I think it was released
uh Paramount is one of the producers I
think it was released in 2017. would you
agree that before the op-ed there was
negative publicity for Mr death about
punching a crew member on a film set
I I heard about that so that's people
who work in Hollywood the Mr definite
edit accusation of assault correct
I I I heard about it yes and would you
agree that there were stories about Mr
depth drinking heavily on the set of
pirates five
uh
there were lots of stories that came out
and I'm sure that uh was one of them and
those stories came out in 2016 and 2017
before the op-ed right
um
again you'd have to show me a timeline
but I'll take your word that there were
articles uh written in various Rags or
or trade public and New York Times Iraq
is that is that what you're saying no
I'm not saying the New York Times is a
rag what I'm saying is
at the height of the metoo movement we
have this op-ed uh directed at Hollywood
and in in the Hollywood I know the rest
of the stuff is background noise now and
Pirates five did not make as much money
in the box office as the prior Pirates
movies did isn't that true
uh that's true it only it made about 800
uh million they made less so than the
first four correct yeah and any company
any company would want to have a a box
office hit that made 800 million dollars
now let's can you put up exhibit uh
defendants exhibit uh 99 please
and if you could blow it up
hey you said the metoo movement started
in 2017 is that is that what you're
saying I'm it actually started long
before that but it picked up steam to
the to the what we now call the metoo
movement in 2017. okay and do you
recognize this article from Dan Wooten
it says how can JK Rowling be genuinely
happy casting wife beater Johnny Depp
and the new Fantastic Beasts film
yes this article is in
the UK's son which I came to prominence
by uh publishing uh topless women on
page three
and the article came out in April on
April 27 2018 correct
I'll I I haven't skimmed through this
but I'll take your your word for it and
it's I think what you're trying to say
was that the sun was a rag so no one
would pay any attention to it is that
what you're trying to say
I'm I'm seeing the sun is the sun uh and
it's in UK and what this article is is a
is repeating stuff from 2016. repeating
all the stuff that you might say should
be all past history after the divorce
it's one one wooten's opinion in in a
newspaper that's claimed to fame as H3
women topless and yeah and Mr nephew the
son over this right what's that Mr depth
sued the sun in the UK about this
article right uh as far as I know he
wanted to uh clear his name that's right
I missed Mr Depp that's what that
lawsuit occurred in 2020 correct it was
tried in 2020.
uh
I believe so yeah and there were
accusations of abuse that came out based
on that lawsuit correct
as far as I know the accusations were
all old news and uh predated much
yeah I mean this is a 2018 article and
in 2020 they probably were rehashing it
and the old news that was coming out in
2018 that would also affect Mr Depp's
reputation correct
again I've tried to draw a line the the
line that Hollywood draws uh uh between
uh the metoo movement and uh starting in
2017 uh and the the
gossip and the the claims back and forth
I mean I there was there was also a
press about Amber Heard being an abuser
uh in those years uh there was also the
other side of the coin but the op-ed
that didn't mention Mr death at all and
didn't mention any accusations that what
happened to her that's what caused Mr
Depp reputational all his reputational
harm that's what you're saying well I
don't agree that this article was not
about they didn't mentioned that's what
I asked you well does she have another
husband who abused her but they didn't
talk about it did it talk at all about
Mr Depp's abuse objection your honor you
he's tried to answer the first question
which was not exactly what this
is actually you ask your question
the op-ed article didn't mention any
specific abuse by Mr Depp towards Amber
Heard correct
uh the only uh name is this is Amber
Heard telling her story that started in
2016 when she was domestically abused
and ignored
now
there were headlines about the UK trial
correct
I'm sure there were yes like
let's burn Amber text allegedly sent by
Johnny Depp about ex reading Court
I didn't hear you let's burn Amber text
allegedly sent by Johnny Depp about X
read in court
yeah and there's a headline from July
19th 2020 that said quote Hollywood
nervously awaits Fallout from explosive
Johnny Depp trial so Hollywood was
following the following the case correct
yeah when was that headline in 2020 20.
yeah I I look uh Johnny Depp is a
decades-long fixture in Hollywood and
people were were following something
across the pond you know we thought we
kind of got rid of the UK in 1776 but
they were still following it absolutely
I mean Mr Depp thought of enough about
this article
to have a three-week trial in the UK
correct objection calls for speculation
about what Mr debb thought I'll sustain
the objection next question there was a
three-week trial in the UK based on this
article by Dan Wooten correct I think
I've said uh Mr Depp uh finally uh had
enough any any suit to clear his name
okay all right
yep you want it
foreign
Mr Marks
you testified that
in the UK case Mr Depp was looking to
clear his name correct
that's my uh assumption yes and yes or
no did Mr Depp clear his name through
that lawsuit
uh I'm uh I wasn't in the UK and I'm uh
not going to uh opine on that that's not
what I've been engaged to talk about you
don't know one way or the other whether
Mr Depp cleared his name through that
lawsuit objection your honor ask an
answer I'll sustain the objection next
question
you understand can you please put up um
exhibit defendants exhibit 115.
in looking through the documents did you
see headlines from October 25th 2018
almost two months before the op-ed the
Mr Depp would not be in Pirate six
I yeah I I saw that there was
speculation uh in different Publications
none uh uh
quoting a Disney executive if you will
not none being definitive
and and by the way I I can't see what
where's this article from I just see the
headline
at dailymail.com
so uh the The Daily Mail is a UK
publication
all right let's move I mean you know or
not
do I know what do you know if it's a UK
publication or not I I
I think that the Daily Mail is but I'm
not sure okay now did you review the
deposition testimony in this case of uh
the Walt Disney corporate designee yes
okay and do you recall that the
corporate designee testified that Disney
produced all documents related to its
business relationship with Mr Depp
including considering Mr Depp for any
work with Disney or future Pirates films
and she did not recall seeing the op-ed
or any documents referring to the op-ed
in that in that production of documents
I I read the uh the deposition I I don't
recall seeing the op-ed in what Disney
produced what I do recall uh is the um
uh that the person giving that
deposition for Disney uh really had no
contact with uh uh Jerry Bruckheimer or
Sean Bailey uh he just was some of the
Disney put up who didn't know anything
is what I can you understand you're a
lawyer right you understand that a
corporate designee is supposed to be in
the shoes of the corporation talking for
Disney correct objection your honor I
think that's outside the scope of his
expertise in this case
overruled okay
I understand that that's what the uh
corporate designee is supposed to be but
when I read that they are not that's
right that was the question in touch
with the president of the company
it gives me pause so Disney itself
represented through this through this
person through this witness that it had
no it did not have the op-ed in any of
its files correct
I don't remember that passage in the um
a deposition uh but I I can't remember
she certainly did not quote the op-ed or
produce the op-ed or talk about the
op-ed
now
but I in Hollywood actions sometimes
speak much louder than words and did you
recall that that same corporate designee
said that pirate six is still possibly
in development
uh until Disney says it's not in
development it's in development okay and
can we put up defendants exhibit 134
.
and you see this is from November 5th
2020. and where's this with this from uh
some uh
Rogue website where is this from
it insidethemagic.com okay okay and it
says Disney reportedly scraps plans for
depths Pirates of the Caribbean sixth
return and that was on November 5th 2020
correct
uh assuming that this is a correct copy
of this random website uh yeah that's
what it says
they're not quoting uh the head of
production it's not a statement by
Disney but that's what this uh woman uh
Rebecca Barton says well two years after
the op-ed it was still a question as to
whether Mr Depp was going to be in
Pirate six
there was no contract for Mr Depp to be
in Pirate six but he was Pirates and uh
there would always be that question
until Pirates has produced or until
Disney says otherwise and November 2020
was at the same time as all the
publicity surrounding the UK case
correct
uh
I I think the UK Judgment Day came out
in November 2020.
and the and this article came out three
days after the Judgment correct
uh if if the Judgment came out on the
second this is three days later in uh
what's this again moviemagic.com
correct by Rebecca uh you know uh Barton
could I approach your honor all right
all right
Now isn't it true that you don't recall
when you first read the op-ed
as I sit here today I don't recall when
I first read it you don't even you don't
I mean it wasn't a big deal to you you
didn't read it in 2018 correct
I have a wife two kids a full-time job I
don't remember okay
and
you have no idea when you first read it
I just want to make sure I understand
that objection asked and answered look I
I wasn't sustain the objection next
question okay I sustained the objection
okay next question
now
you as an expert in the entertainment
field do you know any actresses whose
careers have gotten better after making
accusations of a domestic abuse against
an actor in Hollywood
I think uh you know that the the the the
taint sticks uh and uh to both sides uh
and I I can't think of any actresses who
have uh prevailed uh and who've been
canceled
have you thought do you know of any
actresses whose careers have gotten
better after making accusations of
domestic abuse against a man in
Hollywood I I haven't been asked to
opine on that but I can I certainly will
look into it I I don't think that this
is something the answer is no right you
don't know
again I I assume uh that uh so yesterday
you never thought her career would get
better by bringing this out I don't know
all right thank you I have nothing all
right redirect
Mr Marks you were asked a series of
questions about a number of Publications
and publicity related to Mr Depp um by
Mr nadelhoff do you recall those
questions
he asked a lot of questions about a lot
of articles
and Sir based on your experience in the
entertainment industry do you have an
understanding of what types of
Publications carry the most weight in
Hollywood
the Publications to carry the most
weight in Hollywood
in my opinion after all these decades
are variety Hollywood Reporter uh
Washington Post Wall Street Journal New
York Times those are the Publications
and Mr needlehoff asked you a number of
questions about certain headlines
related to Mr Depp and various news
coverage related to Mr Depp
um do you have an opinion about the
impact of of those articles that you
looked at with Mr nadelhoff on
cross-examination on Mr Depp's
reputation in Hollywood
again I don't remember all the articles
but what I do know is that Johnny Depp
had always had articles about him and
that
that didn't change the Baseline uh a few
had a big project and it had a role for
Johnny Depp that didn't change the
Baseline
is your opinion about the op-ed misheard
author different than that
my opinion about the op-ed in the
Washington Post is is was a different
that was uh uh had a a different quality
of of headline and article
thank you your honor no further
questions is this witness subject to
recall uh he is your honor all right sir
since you're subject to recall the rule
of witness does apply for you so you
cannot discuss your testimony and do not
uh watch any of the case okay sir but
you're free to go today sir okay thank
you thank you all right watch your step
there
all right your next Witness
plaintiff calls Douglas banyo your honor
okay could you spell it last name for me
b a n i a thank you
the your honor may approach for just a
moment okay sure
good afternoon sir
yes ma'am good afternoon Mr Banya
uh will you please State your full name
for the record yes Douglas Banyan
and Mr Banya what do you do for work
I am an intellectual property that
damages and valuation expert
do you have any particular specialty in
your line of work uh yes my specialty is
using internet and social media analysis
when I'm quantifying value or I'm
calculating damages or if I'm analyzing
the impact of social media or Internet
events
where do you work I work at nevium which
is located in San Diego California
how long have you worked there 10 years
what's your position I'm a founding
principal and an analyst
I'd like to talk a little bit about your
educational background for a moment
where did you attend college
I received my bachelor's degree in
cinema from San Diego State University I
graduated in 1997.
and after you graduated in 1997 did you
pursue another degree yes I went
directly to San Diego State University I
got a master's degree in television film
New Media production
was there any particular reason you
chose to go to San Diego State for that
um the new media production side of that
program I really liked this was I
graduated from there in 2000 so this is
even before YouTube was found so the
whole idea of putting film on the
internet and kind of analyzing the
internet and using analytic tools to see
how things are doing on the Internet is
what that's what's what's What attracted
me and that's what I learned there as
well
what did you do after you got your
master's degree
um after the Master's Degree I moved to
Los Angeles and I was an independent
filmmaker for a while then I got
introduced to intellectual property and
I started working for a a small boutique
IP firm back in San Diego what was the
boutique firm you went to
what was the name of the firm yes the
name of the firm was consort
and what what did consort do
consort values intellectual property for
various business reasons they do
litigation Support Services as well
and when you say intellectual property
what do you mean
um when I talk about intellectual
property I'm mostly talking about
um copyrights patents and trademarks uh
I might include related intangible
assets such as domain names websites
internet accounts but IP for me is
mostly brands
publicity rights copyrights trademarks
what type of work did you do while you
were at Consular
um at various positions there but um I
was a research analyst as a financial
analyst
I was the director of Business
Development my last position there was a
principal
and what kinds of things did you work on
uh we worked on you know valuation our
clients you know they needed evaluation
of their IP portfolio for maybe tax or
estate reasons you know a lot of
litigation support like I'm doing now
somebody infringes on a trademark or
publicity rights uh that was actually
the place I got my I was my first expert
witness job I was a named expert on a
right of publicity case
um
representing the retired players of the
NFL against the NFL they're using their
name and likeness without permission so
services such as that
how long did you work at consort
how's that common sore for 10 years
and after concert where did you work
then at nebium where I am now
and did you found nevium yes
what kind of work does nevium do
and the fbm does several things that
provides several Services who we value
intellectual property for various
reasons tax estate to m a business
transactions
um you know we not only provide the
value of a business but we can break
that value what percent of the value is
this trademark portfolio or this patent
portfolio
we do litigation support so like I'm
here I testify in cases you know maybe a
false endorsement case somebody uses a
celebrity's name and likeness without
permission maybe there's a trademark
infringement case he's a brand without
permission
um you know a defamation case such as
this you know what's the impact of
something that was posted online uh
so the Third Kind of bucket of services
we offer
um
is brand monetization strategies so I
think the best way to explain that is is
companies have business plans they have
marketing plans they don't have IP plans
so we come in and work with with
customers with our clients understand
their business and their marketing plans
and help them build an IEP plan that
fits in with those two so they can
essentially make more money off their
branded products and services
um and I think what's important with all
that is you know what differentiates us
with competitors is we use internet and
website analytic tools and all
everything we do you know everything is
online now and um uh understanding those
tools when calculating value or
calculating damages is important
do you have any professional
certifications
uh I am a certified licensing
professional that is a designation given
by the licensing executive Society
um Les Les is a not-for-profit
organization that supports professionals
like me who who deal with a lot of
Licensing
um but I'm a Google analytics individual
I have a Google analytics individual
qualification that is a test given by
Google for those that understand and
pass a test related to
internet Analytics
can you explain a little bit about what
Google analytics is
yeah so Google analytics is a web
service
um
provided by Google and it's used by
business owners and website owners to
understand the traffic that comes to
their websites so essentially once you
sign up for your Google analytics
account you're given a bit of code and
you embed that code into various web
your web pages then you can log in and
you can see like who's coming to my
website what are they doing and really
it's essentially a tool for search
engine optimization you know the goal of
the web is to show up number one in
Google organic so then you you know
you'll tweak your website a bit you'll
look at your analytics see if you're
showing up on on the first page of
Google if not you know you can use those
analytics to keep playing around and try
to end up on the first page of Google
are you a member of any professional
organizations
I'm a member of the international
trademark Association that is a an
organization they're actually having
their annual conference here in DC so I
popping back and forth to that
um I am on their right of publicity
panel I just gave a presentation on
Monday
uh I'm a non-attorney member of uh the
American Bar Association I'm on their
copyright and social media committee
um your honor at this point plaintiff
would um offer Mr Banya as an expert in
Internet and social media analytics all
right aim Jackson
all right so move thank you
Mr Banya what were you asked to do in
this case
I was asked to analyze the impact of the
uh this uh the allegations of domestic
abuse abuse made by Miss heard as it
relates to our 2016 restraining order
and then asked to also analyze the
republication of that uh alleged abuse
in her 2018 Washington Post op-ed
what work have you done in connection
with forming your opinions relative to
that
so I identified the best tools to use in
this case which are Q scores
Google Trends and a historic Google
search results
a few terms in there I just want to
break them down a little bit
what's a q score
uh accuse score is there's a there's a q
Score company that's been around for
about 50 years and what they do is they
measure how well a brand or a celebrity
or Sports character is known and how
much they're liked and they also measure
how much they're disliked
who else besides you uses Q scores
Q scores are used by you know any
company that you know organizations that
license in a celebrity or a brand to
endorse their product or service
um the PGA golf tour is actually using Q
scores right now they're using Q scores
in Google search results they have a
pool of 40 million dollars that they're
going out to their players so depending
on their Google search results and their
Q scores and other metrics I'm sure
they're using those uh to you know
divide up that pool of money
and I think you also mentioned Google
Trends what's that yeah Google Trends is
another service offered by Google
you know as we know everything starts
with a Google search these days there's
you know five billion daily searches on
Google and Google Trends allows a user
like me or you to go into Google Trends
and analyze a search traffic for various
key terms anything you really want maybe
there's a new football player and you
want to see how that football player is
trending compared to the team over time
or maybe something related to you know
Ukraine or maybe a celebrity so Google
Trends just shows you what kind of
search volume is happening during
various points of time
what are historical Google search
results
so historical Google search results are
search using Google there's actually an
area where you can go back in time and
see what was showing up in Google during
that time uh and it's it's really the
best indication of what websites would
have appeared back in time
oftentimes you know working with my
monetization clients we want to know hey
how were you ranking years ago for your
branded service or your branded company
it will go back in time and look and
then in litigation you know we're always
going back in time you know so we want
to figure out what was most likely
happening what websites were served back
then and when you know what websites
were served back then you typically know
what people were reading and thinking
about
why did you choose these particular
tools for your analysis in this case
um
well the Q scores I really thought it
was the best idea to understand Mr
Depp's Q score is right before 2016
before the abuse allegations just to see
where he was at then I wanted to see his
Q scores right after uh the 2016 alleged
abuse allegations and then I wanted to
see his Q scores after the 2018
Washington Post op-ed just to see if
there was any changes during that period
of time
and what about your decision to use
Google Trends and historical Google
search results yeah I mean I felt that
like those two tools together were
perfect because what I wanted to do
uh is understand
you know as I mentioned everyone's going
to Google to figure things out you know
what what were people who when people
Google Johnny Depp prior to these
alleged abuse allegations what websites
were coming up and what was the public
consuming about him then I wanted to
know that after and then after the the
op-ed so I used Google Trends just to
identify the dates in time in which then
I went into the historic Google search
results I searched for Mr debb and then
I changed those dates to go back in time
and then
um I analyzed the top three websites of
each search
based on the analysis you did in this
case have you formed any opinions
yeah my analysis shows that prior to
prior to 2016 and the allegations
um the abuse allegations Mr Depp was not
portrayed in a negative connotation
um
you know that's the first thing that I
that I that I identified did you form
any other conclusions
um
I
I realize that those websites were
coming up were mostly about his career
his characters Johnny Depp as the
individual you know with his interests
then after the
2016 Mark uh you know the majority of
those results turned into negative
things about the abuse allegations and
then even more so after the op-ed there
seemed to be kind of a theme or a flavor
of not only the abuse allegations but
his drinking and and drug use
did that answer your question yes okay
yeah
um Mr Bonnie have you prepared a
demonstrative um that depicts how you
use Google Trends in this case yes
um your honor at this time uh we'd like
permission to approach I have heard
copies
foreign
foreign
and just for the record we've marked
these as plaintiffs uh 1236 for
identification 1236 for identification
do you want to publish to the jury yes
please okay
foreign
can you explain for the jury what is
depicted in this demonstrative that you
prepared yes so this is
um this is the Google Trends data uh
you're gonna see that it runs from 2004
uh into 2020
and you're going to notice the different
spikes
those spikes represent
uh when people were searching for Mr
Depp
you can also notice here I've got the
red line uh just showing the dates uh
when misheard filed the restraining
order oh can I
can I write on this you can touch the
screen yes okay yes sir thank you for
your honor yeah so here I'm talking
about in this line here is is just the
date and time in which misheard alleged
the abuse and filed the restraining
order and then this line here is the
December 18 2018 op-ed and what I wanted
to do
is identify the peaks of interest in Mr
Gap and you're going to notice here I
found 17 spikes of interest that I
analyzed and then the 51 key web pages
we're going to get into later I I've
analyzed the top three search results
for each Spike and then here I I analyze
the seven spikes after uh you know the
2016
allegations of abuse and then again
after the December 18 2018 op-ed
um once you determined these spikes the
periods of significant interest in
searches for Johnny Depp um on Google
what did you do with that information
so
again the purpose of using Google Trends
was just to understand when there's the
most interest in Johnny Depp because for
some reason something was going on in
the news in the media people are turning
to Google to search for Mr Depp so then
I I went to my web browser uh and and
then I I searched for Johnny Depp in
Google but before I did so I have a
separate web browser I call my workbench
browser you know I don't log into
anything it's important to be logged out
of Google because Google keeps a profile
on you and your search results could be
biased based on that profile then also
when you go into a web browser you have
to clear your cache you have to clear
your history clear all your data and
make sure you can get the most unbiased
search results as possible so I went
into Google uh
I typed in Johnny Depp and then I
searched and set the time periods for
the various points here that you see
labeled with letters
do you have a demonstrative that shows
an example of one of those points that
you um you examined yes okay Tom could
we go to um the second uh Tanya
demonstrative please
yeah so this is this is an uh an example
of I believe it was Spike or Point O in
the Google Trends so what I did is I
went into Google I cleared everything as
I as I told you made sure I was logged
out of Google and here you can see I
typed in Johnny Depp I hit the search
and then what I did is went to this tool
area which pulls a drop down area for
the date and I set the date to match the
Google Trend Spike of November of 2004
then we had these top three websites
that came up I I downloaded those
websites and then I analyzed them
so did you do undertake this analysis
for each of the 17 points on the on the
prior slide that we looked at yes
correct and what did you do once you had
your web page results uh such as on this
demonstrative
do you mean when I reviewed each web
page yes yes so what I was looking for
is in a were these web pages or articles
did they have anything to do with the
alleged abuse did they have anything to
do with his alcohol drug use did they
have anything to do with his worth
ethics so I basically you know tried to
understand you know the the content and
and of each website or article
did you look at all of the results that
turned up when you were in these
historical searches
I I only
um
uh reviewed the top three why did you
choose the top three uh so I reviewed
the top three because the research shows
that about 50 to 75 percent of the
people only click on the top three so I
wanted to get the majority of the
searches
I think we can take that down for now
thank you
what did you determine about the results
that you found for the period prior to
Ms heard's first allegations of abuse
so I determined that you know Mr Depp
was not portrayed in any negative
connotation the web results were about
his life and his career as acting his
you know pictures of him you know
relationships he was in you know just
pretty normal stuff
and what did you determine about the top
results after Miss Herb's initial
allegations in 2016 and then the
republication in the op-ed in 2018
okay
foreign
what did you find about the results
um of the top web pages that you
determined after misheard's initial
allegations and then again after the
publication of the op-ed yeah so after
the initial allegations in 2016 I found
that the majority of them had to do with
the alleged shippings
and then after I realized that the the
ones the web pages that we're dealing
with the alleged abuse then started
talking about is is drinking and Drug uh
drinking and doing drugs so it appeared
to me that um you know they became
negative after 2016 but then after 2018
they even included you know the the
alleged abuse but also included this the
drunk uh drinking and drug use
did you form any opinions about the
results that didn't refer to the
allegations of abuse
that didn't I formed an opinion that
um
I'm not following your question I'm
sorry that's all right we can move on
um did any of the results that you
analyzed refer to Mr Depp's work ethic
no
did you form
um any overall opinions about the
results
um in the web pages that you looked at
following Ms heard's accusations of
abuse
yes uh as I stated
um
you know prior to 2016 the web pages
were just about his daily life and and
career after the 2016 marker point they
tended to include the majority of them
included uh you know the allegations of
abuse and then after the 2018 op-ed uh
the ones that included the allegations
of abuse were also talking about
drinking and drug use what was your
overall view of the connotation of those
results then yeah so Mr Depp was
portrayed in a negative connotation
after the
2016 allegations of abuse and even more
so after the 2018.
you mentioned you also looked at Q
scores as part of your analysis how are
Q scores calculated yeah so Q scores
um it's a it's a survey of 1800 people
that happens twice a year uh and
um
what they do is uh it's internet based
and they they measure how well with
celebrity or a brand is known how how
much they're liked and how much they're
disliked few scores you know include
sports figures celebrities even cartoon
characters brands
so that's how the scoring system works
do you have a demonstrative that
reflects the Q score analysis that you
prepared yes okay okay Tom could we have
um
and Mr Banya what does this tell us
about the the Q score analysis that you
completed
yeah so what this is saying again you
know these spikes are the Google Trends
that you've already seen but what I've
overlaid are his Q scores shown in the
red green and purple area
and and as you recall I wanted to find
out his Q score prior to the allegations
of abuse in 2016 where he had a positive
Q score of 11 and a negative Q score I'm
I'm sorry a positive Q score of 35 and a
negative Q score of 11 and then I looked
at the Q scores after and then after the
op-ed
and what did you determine about those Q
scores
yeah so what you can see here is
positive Q score which is represented in
red was a 35 and that was prior to the
alleged abuse in the restraining order
then after that
um his Q score uh positive Q score
dropped to a 31 and what that's saying
is less people liked him after
um
after the the date of the 2016 alleged
abuse and then his negative Q score went
up from an 11 to a 16 which is telling
you that more people disliked him during
that time frame
and what did you find about the final Q
scores that you looked at for Mr duck
yeah then you can see the Q score C that
I have there in purple uh his positive Q
score uh went from a 31 to a 29 his
negative Q score one from a 16 to a 15.
so now it was positive Q score dropped
again from a 31 to a 29 meaning less
people had a positive impression of Mr
death and then his negative Q score did
go from a 16 to a 15 so not as many
people disliked Johnny during that time
frame
what are your overall opinions about The
Q scores that you analyzed
so my overall opinions are you know as I
mentioned earlier I wanted to analyze
the Q scores during this snapshot of
time I wanted to understand what they
were before during and after the op-ed
and what this tells me is his positive Q
score went from a 35 to a 29 and then
his negative went from an 11 to a 15. so
what the Q scores is telling me is the
public perception of Mr Depp has been
damaged you know they they like him less
and they dislike him more
based on all of the analyzes that you
completed in this case what are your
final opinions about Mr Depp's
reputation over this period of time
yeah so my opinions are that you know Mr
Depp was not portrayed in a negative
connotation prior to the 2016
allegations of abuse
and then Mr Depp's uh image he was
portrayed in a negative connotation
after the 2016 allegations of abuse and
then more so after the 2018 Washington
Post op-ed uh and then the Q scores
represent that uh you know the public
thinks he's damaged they think uh less
likely of him his positive excuse Q
score has gone down and they don't like
him even more because it's negative Q
score went from the 11 to the 15.
I have no further questions of this
witness your honor all right ladies and
Gentlemen let's go ahead and take our
afternoon recess of 15 minutes do not
discuss the case and do not do any
outside research just stay right there
for a second sir
come on
all right insertion during the middle of
your testimony did not discuss your case
even with the attorneys at this point or
your testimony okay sir okay all right
you can step down we'll be back in about
15 minutes okay
so let's come back then at 3 35. all
right let's work okay thank you
foreign
foreign
okay one exhibit oh good
this means you're only down one right
that's right okay perfect this is 16 39.
thank you all right
go ahead and get the jury
foreign
all right please be seated all right
cross-examination
good afternoon Mr Banya good afternoon
Mr Banyan you understand that this case
is about the op-ed in December of 2018
correct
I understand this case to be about the
allegations of domestic abuse both
um
as it relates to the 2016 and the
republication of that in the 2018
Washington Post op-ed you understand
that Mr Depp is only suing Amber about
the op-ed from December 2018 correct
my understanding is I can base my
understanding on my analysis which
includes the 2016 allegations that's
your analysis but do you understand what
Mr Depp is suing Amber for in this case
section your honor to the extended calls
for a legal conclusion
the same sustain the objection next
question did you read the complaint in
this case yes did you understand that Mr
Depp was only suing for the op-ed about
the op-ed yes okay
and it's he was not Mr Depp was not
suing Amber in this case from his
complaint about the accusation she made
in 2016 correct
that is my understanding right and
you're not able to separate out how Mr
Depp's reputation was impacted from the
op-ed in 2018 versus how it was impacted
when misheard filed for divorce in 2016.
correct
that's not correct
okay
yes sir
Mr van you took a deposition in this
case yes I did and I was asking you the
questions in that case is that right
that's correct okay
and
you took that deposition on March 21st
2022
that is correct
and you were under oath at the time
correct
yes okay and you're under Earth to tell
the truth correct correct
can you turn to page 83 of your
transcript
which is on the 21st page of the
I'm here okay and you see line nine
yes and I ask you are you able to
separate out how Mr Depp's reputation
was impacted from the op-ed versus how
it was impacted by when misheard filed
for divorce and your answer was no
correct
correct okay
and you're not able to separate out how
Mr Depp's reputation was impacted from
the op-ed in 2018 versus the publicity
surrounding when Mr Depp sued the Sun
newspaper in the United Kingdom when a
sunwriter called Mr deck a wife beater
correct
are you still reading from my deposition
no I'm asking your question now please
repeat that you're not able to separate
out how Mr Depp's reputation was
impacted from the op-ed in 2018 versus
the publicity surrounding when Mr Depp
sued the Sun newspaper in the United
Kingdom when a sunwriter called Mr Depp
a wife beater objection compound your
honor
sustained you're not able to separate
out how Mr Depp's reputation was
impacted from the op-ed in 2018 versus
the publicity surrounding when Mr Depp
sued the Sun newspaper in the United
Kingdom correct my analysis shows that
the
um
the web documents that I reviewed after
the 2018 allegations respectfully this
is a yes or no question this is a yes or
no question
please repeat the question you're not
able to separate out how Mr Depp's
reputation was impacted from the op-ed
in 2018 versus the publicity surrounding
when Mr Depp sued the Sun newspaper in
the United Kingdom that was not part of
my analysis to carve that out
and you didn't you wouldn't you were not
able to separate it correct I didn't try
to okay and so you don't you couldn't
I didn't try it okay
and you understand
that the article Mr Depp sue the sun
over had the headline that said how can
J K Rowling be genuinely happy casting
wife beater Johnny Depp in the new
Fantastic Beasts film correct
uh I don't recall if that's one of the
articles I reviewed
did you unders do you know if that
article came out before Miss Herz op-ed
I don't know okay
now
you're not offering an opinion as to how
the op-ed for misheard in December 2018
impacted Mr Depp's career correct
I'll repeat that please you're not
offering an opinion as to how the op-ed
from misheard in December 2018
impacted Mr Depp's career correct okay
and you're not offering an opinion as to
how the op-ed for misheard in December
2018 impacted Mr Depp's reputation
what I'm doing is it's a yes or no are
you doing are you offering opinion to
that or not
my opinion is related to his Public
Image you're not offering an opinion as
to how the op-ed for misheard in
December 2018 impacted Mr Depp's
reputation correct
I'm not talking to exactly about his
reputation correct
and you're not offering an opinion as to
how the op-ed for misheard in December
2018 impacted Mr Depp's Public Image
correct
I mean I'm offering an opinion that
after the 2018 yes or no other image
it's a yes or no you're not offering an
opinion as to how the op-ed for misheard
in December 2018 impacted Mr Depp's
Public Image
I am turn to your deposition transcript
please
and if you go to page 74 which is on
page 19
.
and you see line area there yes you see
line one
starting on line one I asked you and
you're not going to testify how the
December 2018 op-ed impacted Mr Depp's
Public Image answer that's correct
that that was your testimony at the time
all right well well
perception
at the time correct okay yes and that
was your answer on March 21st 2022
correct
the yes the data the deposition so that
was a month and a half ago right correct
okay
and you're not offering an opinion as to
whether the op-ed for misheard made Mr
debt more hireable or less hirable
correct correct okay
as to the articles that came up in the
Google searches that you spoke about it
was you made the determination whether
the Articles had a quote negative
connotation or not right correct okay
and so that's just your view if an
article had a negative connotation about
Mr Depp right
yes that's my opinion that they had a
negative connotation right so if an
article criticizes Mr def's acting for
example you're not considering that
article as having a negative connotation
about Mr Depp correct
repeat that please so if an article
criticizes Mr Depp's acting you're not
considering that article as having a
negative connotation about Mr Depp
correct correct okay
now in your analysis of Google spikes
the highest spike in searches for Mr
Depp was in January
2004 correct correct okay and can
I guess you guys have it can you put up
the demonstrative 1236
yeah it's published
and can you see that Mr Bank can we can
we make it just a little bit bigger
okay so the if I'm understanding you
correctly
a is where the most searches were
conducted about for Johnny Depp correct
correct and that's from January 2004
correct correct so that was 18 years ago
correct okay and that was when misheard
was 18 years old but I don't know okay
the top Spike you mark as a hundred
correct I did not Mark that but Google
Trends uh identified that's fica's 100.
and where it says 100
you don't know how many people actually
search for Johnny Depp at that point
correct
well the Google Trends algorithm marks
the highest point of search as a hundred
and then everything is compared to that
as a ratio or a percent so if you notice
that a is a hundred everything else is
lower than that because everything is
being compared to that highest point
right so you don't know how many people
actually did the search for Johnny Depp
in January 2004 correct correct it could
be a hundred or could be a million right
I don't know and you don't know if it's
actually human beings doing these
searches correct
as opposed to as opposed to bots or
something like that
I did not do an analysis to determine if
there's a bot or a human being but
Google Trends is a tool that's going to
show you during a time frame the highest
point of search interest as a hundred
okay
but you don't know if it you don't know
if it's humans Bots my cat doing the
searches correct objection asked and
answered your own sustained next
question
foreign
now
in all of these Google spikes
Miss heard's op-ed never came up as one
of the top three searches in any of the
Google spikes correct
well that is correct because Google
Trends is based on a search of a word or
a name and because Mr Depp's name was
not mentioned in that op-ed Google
Trends did not pick that up so person
does a search for Johnny Depp
and the op-ed doesn't come up correct
in my analysis the op-ed did not come up
okay
okay and in fact
the red line the red dotted line is all
the way to the right that shows
when the op-ed was published on December
18th 2018 correct yes okay and the
searches are actually going down right
after the red line correct
as opposed to the searches in 2004.
look at the red line look at the red
dotted line and you have two you have
two points here right there
those go down from the time of the op-ed
correct correct okay and isn't it true
that the next
I guess Spike happens
in March of 2019 correct
right there yes
and do you know that it was March of
2019 when Mr Depp sued Amber Heard in
this case
no I didn't look at that date right you
can look at any articles
for the bit for that for this bullet
correct that's correct okay
and
since Miss heard's op-ed came out on
December 18 2018 you would agree with me
that by definition all the spikes you
analyzed before December 18 2018 could
not have been caused by the op-ed right
correct
so articles about Mr Depp's drug use
before December 2018 could not have been
caused by the op-ed correct
correct okay and you in this chart
analyze only two spikes after the op-ed
isn't that right
that is correct okay
and the first Spike you analyzed after
December 2018
V is V correct yes
and is that from
is that January 2020
roughly yes okay so that's January 2020
is over a year after the op-ed by Miss
hurt correct that's correct okay
and then the next Spike you analyze was
T correct yes
and that was in approximately July 2020.
correct okay so that was a year and a
half after Miss Herz op-ed correct
yes
and again none of the Articles and then
you and then for V and T if I understand
it
you then analyze the top three
searches that come that came up or the
top three websites that came up after a
search
correct okay
and none of the Articles you analyze and
those Google spikes after the op-ed were
the op-ed correct correct okay
and isn't it true that the headlines of
the Articles over a year after the op-ed
that you analyzed were about Mr Depp
suing the sun in the UK for a sun writer
calling Mr Depp a wife beater
you would have to pull those articles
back up I don't have those in front of
me
isn't it true that the article you see
and and just so I understand it V and T
that would mean there were six articles
correct that you analyzed yes okay and
isn't it true that the article on
February 26 2020 the headline was quote
Johnny Depp's disturbing alleged text
messages read aloud in court as libel
lawsuit begins
again I don't have that article in front
of me I did produce those as part of my
analysis I don't have that in front of
me if you'd like to show it to me and
you understand that that was about the
lawsuit against the sun in the UK not
about the op-ed correct
again I did not have that in front of me
and the other another article that came
up on February 27 2020 is one of the top
three hits when you search for Johnny
Depp what the headline was quote let's
burn Amber text allegedly sent by Johnny
Depp about X read in court
I mean if you want to talk about these
articles but we need to bring them up
it's this is your opinion you don't you
don't recall what articles you analyzed
I mean there's a lot of Articles here I
don't I didn't memorize each title there
was there were six articles that you
legalized in the
almost two years after the op-ed would
you can you bring those up and we can
talk about them and on July 19th 2020
the headline was quote Hollywood
nervously awaits Fallout from explosive
Johnny Depp trial
you don't you don't recall one way or
the other whether that was one of the
articles in either V or t
again uh I know if you want to bring up
my documents I know document
9j
909 K and 9M are mentioning the op-ed
again I don't have those and when you
say mentioning the op-ed does that mean
that it just references that Mr Depp
sued Amber Heard in Fairfax no it talks
about how he's alleged to have abused
her that relates to the op-ed doesn't it
say I mean another headline from July
19th 2020 the headline was quote
Hollywood nervously awaits Fallout from
explosive Johnny Depp trial objection
asked and answered sustain the objection
next question you understood that was
about the lawsuit against the sun in the
UK correct
objection let me ask about that
overruled again I would like to talk
about these articles but I need to see
them
and on July 19th 2020 the headline was
quote Johnny Depp versus Amber Heard all
The Nasty bits of the UK trial and it's
all nasty
that was in point T correct
again I do not have that list in front
of me if you'd like to bring that up we
could talk about it and you understood
that was about the lawsuit against the
sun in the UK correct I do not
and on July 19 2020 the headline was
quote Johnny Depp claims in the sun he
beat ex-wife complete lies Court told
that was the quote correct I don't see
that here
that was in your report correct
I I would have to look at the documents
again I would be happy to discuss them
if you would bring those up and then you
previously had a chart that had articles
from November 2020 correct
I'm sorry say that you previously had a
chart that included articles from
November 2020 correct objection
foreign
you understood it was Mr Depp's decision
to sue the sun correct
I I don't know that's not part of my
analysis now
you talked about Q scores and your test
in your direct testimony correct correct
and you testified about three particular
Q scores for Mr Depp right
three periods of time is the Q scores
that I analyzed and you're not offering
an opinion as to why Mr def's Q scores
change correct that's correct
and Q scores can go up and down for
actors for any sort of reason correct
that's possible
you recall testifying that they could go
up and down for any sort of reason in
your deposition
yeah they can go up and down for many
different reasons so you're not offering
an opinion that Mr Depp's Q scores were
damaged because of Miss herd's op-ed
correct that's correct
and in comparing the Q scores from
before the op-ed to the Q scores after
the op-ed
Mr def's Q scores dropped by two points
correct
I I don't have those Q scores in front
of me but if if you're looking at them
we can show we can show the third page
of this demonstrative
what was your question please his Mr
Depp's positive Q scores from B to C
dropped by two points correct yes you're
not an expert on statistics correct
correct and even though you're not an
expert you have an idea about what the
term statistically significant means
correct yes
and statistical significance is a
measure of whether your findings are
meaningful right
yes I don't think you need statistics to
understand Q scores and you don't know
if there's any significance to a drop in
two points in positive Q score correct
so there absolutely is when you're
ordering Q scores
points of time Mr ban you go to your
deposition page 113.
which is on 29.
okay
at 10 Atlanta page 113 line 10 it says
so you're not offering an opinion as to
the significance of a change in Q score
correct answer correct well you're
talking about statistically uh a
difference what I'm talking about is how
we use Q scores in the industry when you
see a q score from dropping from a 31 to
a 29 there's an issue is this somebody
you really want to hire to endorse your
products or your service no you probably
not you want to look into why why what
is going on in the public to to make
these Q scores drop like that and you
don't know exactly the significance
between five or six points of drop and
queue score correct correct okay
foreign
now
and it shows here that Mr Depp's
negative Q score actually got better
from point B to point C correct correct
so that's actually better for Mr dap
correct correct okay and you understood
you understand that Dr Alan Jacobs
reviewed your opinions in this case yes
and you understand that Dr Jacobs
reviewed additional Q score data correct
yes okay can we please put up
plaintiff's exhibit 889
at 117.
Mr Banya do you understand this as a
chart of Mr Depp's Q scores
from Winter 2012 through summer of 2021
yes
do you have any reason to question the Q
scores
that are that are just that are shown in
this chart
like I said my deposition I've not
received the actual data to build this
chart but I don't have any reason to to
not believe that this is accurate as I
understand it Q scores are performed on
a celebrity like Mr Depp twice a year
correct
yes so there's winter of a particular
year and then there's
summer of a particular Year yes and the
winter scores come out around February
is that right but I don't have that
information in front of me but it sounds
right and so would you know when the
summer scores come out uh I don't okay
and this chart shows
well permission to publish this chart as
a demonstrator of your honor any
objection
I don't think this witness has laid an
appropriate foundation for your honor he
said he has no reason to question the Q
scores out loud as a dimension that's
fine
foreign
and so this chart shows Mr Depp's
positive and negative Q scores correct
correct and the positive Q scores are in
blue
that's correct
can you blow it up a little bit Michelle
and
and the negative Q scores are in red
yes okay objection your honor may we
approach
Mr Banyan the positive Q score for Mr
Depp in the winter of 2012
is 42 correct
it's in between yeah it's in between 40
and 45. okay
and if we if
did you check this actual Q scores that
um
Mr Jacobs
demonstrated in his report
no my analysis was a snapshot of time I
wanted to know Johnny Depp's Q scores
directly before the 2012 allegations the
2016 allegations of abuse and after it's
okay and you see here that the positive
Q scores for Mr Depp dropped from 42 in
the winter of 2012.
to
35
in the summer of 2016 correct
yes that's a seven point drop correct
yes and that's before Miss heard had her
divorce filing correct that's correct
okay
and that drop in Mr Depp's positive Q
scores could have nothing to do
with Miss heard's op-ed correct
correct and that drop could have nothing
to do with the allegations misheard made
after the divorce filing correct correct
and
would you agree
that
the
positive
Q scores
actually start to show an increase for
Mr Depp
after the op-ed
there's a decrease and then there's an
increase yep
and the same for the negative
debt Q scores
there's a bit of a positive
and then it goes down correct yes
so really the op-ed had no effect on Mr
Depp's Q scores correct
as I mentioned my analysis looked at the
snapshot of time and it shows that he
was harmed you know from before the
allegations of abuse in 16 to after the
op-ed in 2018. you looked at three Q
scores
and you could have looked at one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
sixteen Seventeen eighteen I won't even
count the 2021 scores 18 Q scores
correct yep okay and you looked at three
right that's correct and and that's what
you're basing your opinion on that the
op-ed damaged Mr Depp's Q scores yeah so
we need that that's right my question is
the yes or no your Council can come back
sorry if you can just answer his
question no questions all right that's
fine
I didn't hear your question I
you looked at three Q scores instead of
18 Q scores correct that's correct okay
and did you look at the Q scores at all
after the Dan Wooten article that came
out in April of of uh 2018.
objection asked an answer General I
don't think I asked that overrule
download
no okay
thank you I have nothing there all right
redirect
Mr Banya on cross-examination you were
asked some questions about uh the fact
that you made a determination about
which of these articles had a negative
connotation do you recall that yes
is that something that you do in uh
situations other than in your analysis
in this case
yeah yeah it's so in non-litigation when
we're building brand monetization
strategies especially if you're going to
work with the celebrity or celebrity or
an athlete you want to look at what's
going on out there you know about that
personality you know because celebrities
and athletes you know Q scores can go up
and down you want to analyze the the
time and see what's going on out in the
media do I really want my client to
license in a celebrity that there's
problems out there or an athlete so yes
it's important to look at this
and I believe you were asked um whether
you're offering an opinion in this case
about the impact of the op-ed on Mr
Depp's Public Image do you recall that
yes and I believe you testified that you
are offering an opinion on that is that
right yes what's that opinion well the
opinion is that uh he's portrayed in a
negative connotation after that date
and with respect to the Q scores that
you analyzed um Mr nadelhoff was asking
you about the three points in time that
you looked at why in your opinion was it
appropriate to look at just those three
Q scores
yeah as I was trying to explain you know
Q scores do go up and down we're
analyzing a period of time we want to
see what's happening right before an
event during that event and if there's
another event after that event and that
is our area of analysis
uh so that's why just these three sets
of Q scores are the appropriate way to
Analyze This
thank you I have nothing further all
right is this witness subject to recall
uh he is your honor all right sir do not
discuss your testimony with anybody
since you're a subject to recall but
since you are an expert you are allowed
to stay in the courtroom if you wish
okay okay all right thank you sir all
right you can step down
all right your next Witness
you're on a I believe we're calling
Aaron fellati by deposition oh okay
could you put I'm sorry could you put
your microphone we approached there's
two exhibits that we have all right well
we're
all right your next witness then thank
your honor uh plaintiff calls Aaron
falotti also known as Aaron Boren
filotti and
um Miss Hertz Council Begins the
questioning thank you
provide your full name
and it is Borum your maiden name right
okay so Borum was your name your last
name in the 2014 to 2016 time frame
correct that's correct
Have you communicated with anybody else
from Mr Depp's uh Council other than
Miss Vasquez
uh not that I recall oh excuse me excuse
me I do
um
I don't remember his name I'm so sorry
I feel like I spoke at home I don't know
his last name
did you speak to or communicate with
Adam Waldman
perhaps I don't recall his last name
and do you call when that occurred
that
would have been
2019
because I had I had a newborn at that
time
so
maybe May June July something like that
2019.
so this is a text exchange between you
and Mr Waldman
it appears so
and you recall speaking to Mr Waldman at
all
yes
and you recall that when you were uh
communicating with Mr Waldman Mr Waldman
was Mr Depp's attorney
yes
miss vladier a trained nurse is that
correct
that's correct
do you have any specialties
well I haven't been working
you know like I used to but previously
uh I was trained in addictions
and mental health
and when you say addictions Are there
specific type of addictions you were
trained in
oh but I primarily worked with chemical
dependency
and where did you receive training for
um
addiction and mental health
different
employment places and then I became a
certified registered addiction source
foreign
did you did you work for Dr Kipper
hey not directly but he would hire the
agency I provided nursing services for
which was
turning point I believe
so I worked under his guidance but not
specifically for him
most of the time there have been times
where I've worked specifically for him
okay when did you start working for uh
Turning Point Nursing services or
whatever the name of that company was
I
think this would be
somewhere between
2007 square feet
and when did you start to begin to do
any work for Dr Kipper
I believe 2014.
what were the circumstances that started
you working for Dr Kipper in 2014.
I recall correctly it would be for
services for Ms heard
were you ever responsible for Mr def's
nursing care while he was under the
treatment of Dr Kipper
invited him with
candidates too
so miss Pilates I'm showing you what's
been marked as exhibit two to your
deposition
and these are you these are ah tpd
16 929
through
16 959 and as as that the paper
documents you have a set of the paper
documents you have in front of you
whatever
and the first page you might have said
at the bottom also uh
k182
yes I have that okay
do you recognize these as your what what
are these
these are my
nursing notes
except for Miss heard
and these are notes you created
yes
did you create these notes in the
ordinary course of business
yes
um
were you trained and how to prepare
these notes
yes would you write these when
how long after you the visit would you
write up these notes
would depend sometimes I would keep
notes on my phone that I would transfer
to the word document when I when I was
in front of my laptop
and if not possible I would do it
as soon as feasible
and how often would you show these notes
to Dr Kipper
I don't recall at intervals but I don't
recall
um so if you look at the first page of
the notes
um the first the first entry is August
27 2014 correct
yes
and
uh you wrote RN has been hired to
provide private nursing care for client
Amber Heard
right right
and RN refer to you correct
uh and an RN means registered nurse
correct
correct
um
and throughout the notes and you say
this here Amber Heard would be referred
to as client or ah correct
and and Johnny Depp would be referred to
as JD
would you agree that Mr Beth and Amber
would get into verbal arguments they
recall a general sense of Discord in the
relationship
what do you mean by General sense of
Discord
called there being disagreements
reconciliation and kind of that
repeating pattern
and would you be at times taking care of
Amber because of this the disagreements
between Mr Depp and Amber
I provided emotional support I was not
present with her often but it was
available
over the phone via text and sometimes in
person
do you recall uh that in March 2015 uh
amber went to Australia to be with Mr
Depp
Mr the dates I would have to look
through documentation to answer Jane the
exact dates okay
and on the exhibit two
this is your note of March 7th 2015.
that's correct
and you wrote a client notifies RM via
text of increasing anxiety
and then on 3 8 15 you wrote RN received
report from Debbie
RN Debbie being Debbie Lloyd correct
that's correct
do you recall what the report you
received was
on March 8th 2015 from Debbie
I mean I'm just reading my notes sure
so to answer your question no I don't
recall specifics of what the report
would have been
I assume based on this note
that would have been a phone call
okay and it says client will be
returning to Los Angeles on March 9th
2015 accompanied by house manager Ben do
you see that yeah
did you have an understanding as to why
Amber was leaving Australia
in March of 2015.
yes
I don't know if this
is you know better than I there was an
incident in
Australia
and they had to be misheard and Mr death
had to be separated
so Ms heard returned to Los Angeles for
my my nursing notes and I believe Mr
Jack must have stayed in Australia
what was your understanding as to why Mr
Depp and Amber had to be separated
it's hard to call
specifics because I wasn't
there or involved at the time but became
involved again I remember
hearing from other people that there was
quite an argument
between the two
in Australia
do you have any understanding if anyone
was injured
during
um
the argument between the argument
between Amber and Mr death
physically injured physically yeah
again I wasn't present so I'm only
speaking
as to what I recall
during that time period And what I sort
of remember hearing from others and also
I just remember
Mr Depp's
finger was injured
I can't tell you specifically which one
but I remember there was an injury to
his finger
do you have any understanding as to how
his finger was injured
no and then
um Aaron you wrote the next note on
March 9th 2015 that says RN and CT and
touch via text and phone calls after a
client arrived at 1500.
yes I wrote that
and 1500 that you're using military time
correct
correct so that would be 3 P.M
correct and you were a client expressed
feeling quote sad
right
you recall what Amber was said about
approximately March 9th 2015.
I can't
today you know I don't remember
specifically but I would assume based on
my March 8th note I would make the
assumption that those feelings were in
relation to the relationship issues
you wrote client states she would like
to discuss recent events between her and
husband with RN and private tomorrow
plans are made for RN to visit client at
her home tomorrow
yes I wrote that do you recall all the
conversation you had with Amber
regarding the events between her and Mr
death at this March around this March
9th 2015 time frame
no I don't recall specifics you recall
anything in general
I really don't I'm sorry
admit did did Amber express any um
fear of Mr Depp at this time
don't recall I don't
I don't see that in this note so I I
can't speak to that
um and then the note for uh March 10th
2015 you see that note thank you you can
take this down
[Music]
okay
we put up attached from 25 please
I'm showing you a text chain between you
and Whitney heard
on March 23 2015. do you see that
and on March uh 23rd 2015 you texted to
Whitney heard Debbie just told me what's
going on and to check with you is Amber
awake or fall asleep do you see that
bill
and then miss her wrote she finally fell
asleep you see that
yes
okay then you wrote thank goodness she
must be exhausted I'm sorry just just to
confirm this is
this is from
Whitney heard not
Amber Heard correct
as I understand it it says heard it is
that your understanding
I assume thank you
and then you if you are called over
communicating with Whitney via text or
chat
that sounds familiar okay
and you wrote thank goodness she must be
exhausted you want me to come to the
loft or is she safe and sound asleep
you see that did you see that okay
and then Whitney wrote safe question
mark no she's not
kept saying she wants to kill herself
you see that
see that
were you ever concerned about misheard
safety as it relates to Mr death
so
if she made comments
to me that she was not safe
I would
be concerned
about her to ensure that she was safe
yes
do you recall miss her making comments
to you about her safety
I remember a general sense when
they meaning misheard and Mr death would
have arguments she would often have her
friends around her for support
but from a
General
you know physical sense she was she was
always in a safe place
and you mean where you mean in a general
physical sense she was always in a safe
place what do you mean by that
meaning she was always
not always I should say often home often
surrounded with friends she had friends
that lived right down the hallway from
her so she was
always supported
was was Mr Depp friends with Marilyn
Manson
yes I believe
Ms Pilates I'm showing you
it's marked as exhibit seven and these
are
texts that Mr Gap produced between you
and him
and I'm focusing on this text message of
October 31st 2015. you see that
well so this text message between you
and Whitney is on March 23 2015. you see
that thank you okay and if we go back to
exhibit two
and I'll go back
um
um there there's no entry for March 23rd
2015. you see that
not everything you did for misheard as
an as a nurse is reflected in these
notes correct
and the next notes we have are November
25th 2015.
do you know why there's
along
um
period where there's no notes
yes
perhaps I can shed some light
for you and everyone on the relationship
when I was first hired to care for Ms
heard
I worked full-time you know I was
assigned
24 7 basically
and after a period of time I became more
part-time and on call
and I was working with different clients
at the time so I would
how to put it I wouldn't not be working
regularly
but would also be available if an issue
arose or a medication change needed or
things like that so
I would assume that would account for
this this Gap
how did you move from um
full-time to part-time
I don't know the exact answer but I I
assume that's not my decision to make
that's usually the client and or
treating physician
okay so that's the first page of exhibit
two
yes thank you
so if you can
um can you go down to it's about the
Third
paragraph a little bit yes
her report from JD
which refers to Mr Jeff
Debbie RN and Dr Kipper
client ah which is miss her
has reportedly been experiencing
increased anxiety and agitation recently
and has had several outbursts of anger
and rage
from what I remember when I was involved
in the case it was to help assist Ms
heard
with some emotional issues anxiety
issues
um in in attempts to assist
in layman's from kind of calming things
down a bit
do you recall any
um examples
that you knew of of anger and rage
showed by Amber
I didn't call her being her very angry
have to refer to my notes it was in
London so that would have been 2014.
and I believe it was in reference to a
violating incident where her phone had
been packed and she was quite upset
I saw her angry at that time and other
times I don't recall
were you in London with Amber at the
time
and how was how was Amber showing her
anger
and recalled
loud
kind of elevated uh voice
yelling crying
uh quite upset
do you recall receiving a call
from Amber
um
around December 16 2015 regarding
this argument between Mr Depp and Amber
all specific phone call
would you doubt that a phone call
occurred if there's if you wrote it down
in your notes
and now you see the note on
December 17 2015.
yes
and you wrote RN in contact with clients
and notify her that she'd be able to
deliver medications to her home
Aaron waited a door for several minutes
after knocking client greeted or in the
door looking disheveled hair appeared
unbrushed client appeared weepy and sad
Pastor is slouched client told Aaron
about argument with husband
aren't over offered emotional support
but reminded client that RN could not
stay as was on duty with another client
and was only visiting in order to
deliver medication
per client she had not been
she had not had contact with husband
since altercation client had visible
bright red blood appearing at Center of
lower lip when RN made client aware that
she acted was actively bleeding on her
lip clients stated it was from injury
sustained in the and then it's blank you
see that we keep going down in the
argument between her and her husband and
then it continues to bleed actively you
wrote that
yes
and then you also wrote clients also
states that her head is bruised and that
she lost clumps of hair and altercation
you wrote that
I assume so it's in my notes okay and
then you wrote Aaron briefly with the
client's scalp but was unable to
visualize the hemato the hematoma's
client had described
he wrote that
yes I would agree and then you wrote RN
encourage clients to be seen by position
Dr pipper or go to emergency
urgent care for thorough assessment you
see that
idea and then you were a client State
she will contact Dr Kipper tomorrow
client is supported by friends Rocky and
IO who will be staying in clients home
with her you were with that
I agree yes
okay and then on December 18th 2015 you
wrote client State she went to Dr
Kipper's office and was assessed by NP
Monroe t as Dr Kipper was out of the
office he wrote that
yes an NP stands for nurse practitioner
that's correct
and you understand Monroe T stood from
Monroe tinker
yes
you'll recall Mr death ever forgot to
take any of his medication
a specific time or ever
again at any time where you're working
with them
I would say vaguely yes
Mr body I'm showing it's been marked as
exhibit 11.
to your deposition which is
Pilates 96
through
106. you see that
you recall receive and you recall
receiving this text message right
vague memory of this
you recall if you spoke to Amber after
you received this text message
or at any time after you receive this
text message around May 21st May 22nd
2016.
are you saying
uh or just
uh I don't really recall
it could have happened you just don't
recall one way or the other
I would agree with that
and you received this picture from Amber
that's correct
what is this picture of
you want it just miss heard
and does the picture show redness on
under Miss heard's eyes
you can ask answer as a lay person if
she has such an opinion
if you have an opinion one way or the
other you can let them know
I'm not an expert so
if I don't know what's what
he received this first picture
of Amber at 12 36 a.m correct
that's the time stamp there
and you received another picture
at 12 36 A.M
it appears so
and who do you see in that picture
also miss Serge
and you received a third picture of
Amber at 12 36 A.M
yes of yourself
and is the third picture of amber
yes that's the third
and you receive the fourth picture of
Amber at 12 36 A.M
then yes
and and that's worth okay I thank you so
it's clear the fourth picture is of
Amber
that's correct and you received that at
12 36 A.M
yes that's the time stamp
and these are pictures of Amber's face
correct
yes that's a picture of her face and
neck
do you recall if you do you recall and
you were probably receiving those
pictures
like I said I have a vague memory of of
this but I don't specifically remember
this evening
um okay do you know if you reported
these pictures
or
what Miss heard reported to you to Dr
Kipper
I would assume that if any information
uh was presented to me I would have
contacted Dr Kipper and you know how you
would have contacted Dr Pepper
no I I
would call email text
you recall if you wrote nurse notes
for this incident
I don't recall
you want us to look at it exhibit two
it's the nursing house yeah yeah why
don't we do that
so there's notes for May 11 2016. you
see that
yeah
and then the next notes for May 26 2016.
okay do you know why you didn't include
notes for May 21st 2016.
and on May 26th you wrote client texted
RN requesting Ambien as she states She's
suffering from insomnia due to stress
and anxiety
client reports quote having the hardest
week of my life
end quote you wrote that
and you were a client states you cannot
deal with the negative media publicity
she has received
surrounding the divorce she requested
from her husband JD
Dr Kipper notified Ambien 10 milligrams
qhs PRN 14 order for Dr Kipper client is
encouraged to make appointment with Dr
Kipper in office to be assessed the
client did not respond he wrote that
yes
Miss bloody I'm showing you it's been
marked as exhibit 12 to your deposition
which is
Pilates 114 through 119.
um
you can take a look through them uh it
appears to be notes of your of when you
were Mr depths
nurse as opposed to miss heard
but feel free to take a look
that's correct I I think these are
Mr or excuse me my nursing notes in
relation to Mr death
so client now is Mr Bat correct that's
correct because these nursing notes
are in reference to Mr Jeff yes that's
correct okay and in the nursing note for
April 23 2015 you wrote
um
that Dr Kipper will introduce Rosalind
Phillip to Debbie RN and clients Amber H
and Johnny Depp Debbie rml assistant in
coordinating session appointments
between clients and Miss Phillips if you
know if Mr Depp and Amber ever saw
Rosalind Phillip
I don't know
it had
pilate 117
shows
notes for June 7th 2016. come on
that is correct
you wrote The Following medications were
approved per Dr Kipper to be given to
the client
and then there's a list of medications
uh
you you wrote that you wrote these notes
correct
understand that Mr death was taking
those those medications as of June 7th
2016.
for this nursing note it appears that he
was
taking these medications listed
and then there's a nurse saying notes
for June 26 2016. see that
yes
um
and it says uh you wrote client is going
through divorce with wife Amber H and is
dealing with the loss of his mother
passed away one month ago
client was provided with the worst
request from wife ah three days after
mother passed away do you see that
yes you wrote that
yes so is it your understanding that
Amber asked for a divorce
this note says that
Mr Depp was provided with divorce
request
from
Ms heard so it appears she she was the
one
requesting it for us right and he wrote
next client states he was not aware ah
won a divorce and expresses confusion
regarding age his desire to terminate
marriage he wrote that
yes is that what Mr Depp told you
I would assume if I wrote it in my net
in my notes
then you wrote uh client's divorce has
been highly publicized and wife ah has
been has been accused him of several
character damaging allegations including
domestic violence
you wrote that correct
correct
was was this uninformed did you write
this based on information Mr Depp
provided you
I don't know I would assume that I've
had discussions with him regarding this
considering that this is a nursing note
for Mr duck
can Mr Depp tell you his character had
been damaged as of June 2016.
I don't recall I have to go by what my
note says here so it alludes to deaths
something that he had discussed
and you you see where he wrote client
states he felt helpless previously but
is now angry at age and wants to clear
his name Mr Jeff told you that
again I don't recall for sure but I
would go back to my nursing notes
because those were written more at the
time so I would assume that he and I
discussed that
okay farther down
um you wrote RN assisted client in
processing feelings and encouraged
clients to continue utilizing individual
therapy as he responded well to RN's use
of therapeutic communication you see
that
yes and you wrote that correct yes
then your client is resistant stating
quote I don't want anyone like Amber's
white therapist he has only made things
worse end quote you see that
yes and you wrote that
yes
and words quotes I don't want anyone
like Amber's therapist he's only made
things worse that was something that Mr
Depp told you
again as I have it in quotations I
assume he made that statement
a little farther down you wrote
throughout Aaron's visit client
maintains attention and is actively
participating in conversation client
consume three vodka drinks during RN
sevenf seven hour visit
client did not eat during visit and
drank water only with several prompts
from our end our uneducated client on
possible interactions between prescribed
medication and alcohol
client verbalize understanding but
stated quote right now I need a little
alcohol for all the bad things I'm going
through end quote
you you wrote those lines
yes
say The Document Speaks best as to how
much how many drinks Mr Depp had
and that Mr depth drank vodka drink
three vodka drinks during your visit
that's what my note says
then you then you said RN provided
one-on-one emotional support and
encouraged clients limit and are abstain
from alcohol and illicit drugs
you wrote that
yes
um you
you recall why you told Mr Depp to
abstain from illicit drugs
no but I did I did and not just with Mr
Duff but in my line of nursing provide
education always with any medication
clients are on and uh contraindications
you know if Mr debba ever took any list
of drugs during during the two during
the 2014 to 2016 time frame
I don't know I didn't I didn't witness
him using any illicit drugs so I can't
speak to that
your honor at this point the questioning
switches over to questions for um by
Council for Mr debb
ie
that's all right with us your honor
I'm sorry let's go ahead and break for
the evening we will see you uh in the
morning just do not discuss the case and
do not do any outside research all right
and we'll have the rest of this tomorrow
morning okay thank you
thank you
all right so we'll see everybody at 10
o'clock tomorrow okay thank you thank
you
foreign
foreign
thank you
we got your back
is it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign